result of the covet 19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rules 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this public meeting is a work session
to discuss the budgets with
police standards and training the
lottery
and the fishing game and fishing game
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order
i am confirming that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules
and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
should email lba underscore
fiscal at leg
state in the event the public is unable
to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
the lba staff are on the meeting
assisting us please note
that all votes that are taken during
this meeting
shall be done by roll call let's start
the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
so thank you and uh representative lin
if you would call the role
yes thank you all right uh first uh
representative umberger
i'm in my home and my husband is
someplace uh vice chair uh
representative daniels
uh representative petra uh it's
representative peter here in farmington
my wife and the dog again are friggin
roaming around the house they're not
necessarily in their own
all right uh i'm i'm here uh present and
i'm uh
at my home uh my wife and son are in the
house but not in this room
uh representative buco uh yes i'm i'm
present i'm home at
in in conway and i'm at my house uh and
no one else is
here representative heath
uh good morning mary heath i'm here in
my home in manchester new hampshire
and i am home alone and representative
murray
good morning i'm home in newcastle um
i'm alone in my office my husband's in
the basement and the dog is somewhere
all right thank you uh so all all
members are present
okay mickey if you would bring uh mr
skippy
in i'd appreciate it i'm also going to
bring in ms ames who's with the police
standards and training council
uh in case she needs to just speak as
part of the presentation as well
good morning good morning uh
the chair members uh hi uh
ms john skip i'm the director of police
standards and training
uh i am in my home in exeter uh i do
have an adult son
who's uh sleeping in after working the
second shift
and he's in a great okay
well welcome to division two and i know
this
is your uh your first time coming to see
us we are actually very nice people
and uh but our responsibility
is to ask questions and to
determine whether the governor's budget
is where we want to be and what we want
to do
so um i will turn it over to you
i would ask if you prefer us to
hold our questions or if you would like
us
to ask questions as we go along
uh madam chair i would uh defer to you
and the
committee in terms of ask asking
questions um
during the presentation or at the very
end whichever is going to work better
for the members of the committee okay
that's fine so folks you heard
what was indicated and so if you have a
question
as he's going through please raise your
hand and
we will call on you and if everyone
except mr scipia could mute
that would be a good thing
including me thank you madam chair
uh this is uh clearly uh
experience for me and uh so i have some
uh
formal words kind of uh ready to go and
then
uh i am happy to uh to answer any
questions or provide any details
to the materials that i sent forth again
my name is john skipa
i am the director of new hampshire
police centers and training council
the mission of new hampshire police
anderson training
is to shape sustain and strengthen the
competency
and professionalism of new hampshire law
enforcement in service to our state
and we accomplish that mission every day
by meeting our dual responsibilities of
providing high quality innovative
credible and responsive basic advance in
it specialized training
and by adopting and enforcing reasonable
professional standards in a manner
consistent with law
and considerate to the public trust
and committed to basic values and the
highest ethical standards
before you should be a
seven page document uh that i prepared
uh this is our agency budget overview
and uh there are some uh
i would say some noticeable deltas
in some of the line items uh and i'm
happy to uh self-identify those
and and offer uh explanations uh
or i am happy to uh just entertain the
questions
of from any member of the committee if
that's more expedient
yeah go ahead and go through what all of
those are
and if we have questions we'll ask
if i if we refer to the page
1300 of the governor's
budget uh i'd like to just speak to some
of the
uh the deltas that uh exist there
uh in on page 1300
under line zero one one
uh which is non-classified salaries
you'll see that there was between
actuals and adjusted
there's a bit of a difference there and
that is just indicative
of the fact that i was hired in march
and so we did not expend all those funds
simply because
the position was not filled
uh in line zero
two zero which is under current expenses
uh that line is used
to kind of cover the cost of consumable
items
that we use during the course of our
business
to include paper towels cleaning
supplies
those kinds of things because of the
pandemic
and uh our inability to run our
operation in a normal way which is a
residential academy
we did not incur expenses
uh to address 65 people living in our
building
pretty much all year we conducted a vast
majority of our training during this
pandemic
whenever possible over zoom and
only brought the recruit officers back
into the building
uh when we really needed to for those
hands-on and skills development classes
that we teach
and that's why you see that that delta
there between
in line zero two four zero two four
uh speaks to the maintenance other than
building in grounds
and you'll notice that this is a there's
a huge
uh change a huge delta between
our 2122 and
the budget going forward 2223
specifically the
increase is uh caused
by two
new items and i'll i'll call them new
the first one is
uh that we were in desperate need
of a record management system slash
training management system uh presently
uh our uh the way that we manage
files and information is is
very antiquated uh we still candidly use
a fax machine
uh to have people fill out uh
applications
to to attend training here at the
academy
uh this was uh an issue that was
identified
in a 2018 i believe it was 2018
maybe 2019 check that it was a 2019
audit that had been conducted by the
legislative
budget assistance uh division
and uh and then certainly uh during the
leak commission
uh the commission recognized
uh the the vital importance of being
able to maintain
very accurate records to
allow us the opportunity to track uh
each
officer's training and to
be very organized with regard to
the if there's any disciplinary issues
so this record management system was
something that was identified from
two different sources uh unrelated
sources the the
uh lba audit and uh the leak commission
pstc had actually set aside
funding uh but in response to the
pandemic
initially uh the governor asked all
state agencies to
um hold off on any purchases and so we
held off
using those capital funds for the
initial purchase
until such time as uh the state could
reassess the governor could reassess
where we were financially
and ultimately allowed for
us to expand those capital funds
the increase that you see there
will be the the annual cost going
forward to maintain that
learning management system record
management system uh we are working with
uh the vendor that we ultimately went
with and they are in the process
of uh customizing that system so that it
works for us exactly the way we want it
uh there's a second piece to that
increase
we have a device a training device that
we use here at the academy
we refer to it as the vertra the virtra
is a
360 decision making simulator
and uh we can train a number of police
officers
uh at a time uh without expending
uh live ammunition or simunitions
ammunition
and we can do it in a very very safe way
again
this is a device that relies heavily
on uh software and computers and things
of that nature
and uh for that reason uh we have annual
subscriptions that we have to uh
put forth to maintain uh the virtual
device
and so uh two big increases there
and and those are the reasons uh for
the um as we move
and again uh i will point you to
line zero one zero
and uh that speaks to
personnel
you'll see that there's a a a jump in
the full-time line
the the commission recognized
a number of uh
things that they wanted addressed in the
area of training
of our police officers here in new
hampshire
and as a commission member uh i
supported
uh all of those recommendations
uh the the truth is that um
the training mandates have now imposed
uh a greater workload where our existing
resources
just can't handle uh the extra workload
that came from those mandates
and so i requested uh
support from the governor to allow
for the addition of one extra training
specialist full-time and
uh also a full-time instructional design
person uh clearly the training
specialist
will assist in uh
looking at our curriculum helping us
uh deliver more scenario-based training
which was an important piece from the
leak commission
uh one thing that the academy really has
never had before
in all the time that it's been in
existence and this is our 50th
anniversary this year so we're very
excited about that
but we have never had an instructional
design person
on our staff uh candidly
all of our training specialists who are
excellent trainers in every regard
uh their their primary uh focus
is law enforcement and i believe uh
we had up until a retirement last year
we had two people who have formal
educations in curriculum
development and adult education
it's important that we have an
instructional design person for two
reasons the first reason
is that uh the trainers
while they write curriculum they also
have to deliver the training
and so a vast majority of the time they
are engaged directly with
i don't like that the other
very important piece is that
we are moving towards developing and
deploying
a high quality online training
using our our online training system
it's important that as the primary
source of in-service training for new
hampshire police officers
we are able to do this so that we can
deliver
in-service training in a very fiscally
responsible way
where we can push training out online
and
uh that assists every city in town
to allow their officers to receive that
training
without uh having to travel to the
academy
and uh it alleviates the problem of
backfilling or paying overtime
uh from the source agency and uh this is
uh
clearly uh the single best way for us
to make sure that training is consistent
across the board
it is accessible across the state and
you know we we have a responsibility and
i have a responsibility to make sure
that
a three-person police department has the
same
equal access to this training as as a
large city police agency does
uh and and so um there's going to be a
little bit of a heavy lift in the front
to develop the content and keep the
content going i have excellent
uh excellent bureau commander that's
uh leading this charge right now we i
have some excellent people that are
assisting
uh but we really do need that
instructional design person to work in
the background
uh to help build out in the kind of the
technical side
of putting that training content
into the computer and being able to
manage it in an
the um the next
real big delta that you'll see is i'll
direct your attention to
line zero two one uh i have a question
yes ma'am you wanna do it now or do you
wanna wait until later
oh no i i'm happy to answer any question
you might have
can you just say a little more about the
training specialists and the
instructional design specialists i guess
two things one
where do they get trained and you know
are they boots on the ground are they
academics is it a combination of both
secondly are you looking for any because
some of this the sensitivity training
um are you looking what particular
considerations are you giving to the
thank you that uh excellent question and
just to answer the the first piece
uh the the uh training specialists
are uh proven law enforcement officers
uh who have a high level of experience
working as police officers and
supervisors
of police officers before they come to
our target audience for the recruit
training
uh is are those people who are coming
into the business so they have no
real foundation uh so a vast majority of
the training specialists
uh come to us from their agencies
as field training officers uh corporals
sergeants
uh lieutenants they and and those are
really the people i need i need people
who
can model mentor uh
and speak with uh legitimacy because
uh they come from the very place that
we're preparing these officers to go to
which is
in a police car uh responding to calls
for service
understand that uh and and i
appreciate the fact that you recognize
that we really have to have a foot
in in two different places we have to
have a foot
in the world of law enforcement and they
have to be excellent police officers to
teach here
on top of that they have to have a very
very strong
understanding of adult learning theory
uh curriculum design and instructional
delivery
and in candidly in some of those cases
i have to take really really good cops
and then make sure that they have uh a
clear and firm understanding on
curriculum development and instructional
design
so they receive ongoing training both
in their their topic areas so for
instance i have a firearms instructor
the lead firearms instructors preparing
to
go to a a firearms instructor
uh program uh in connecticut once
once covid kind of settles down
i have uh i have uh an
in-service class that we're getting
ready to deliver on instructional design
and then the train the trainer
instructional design
and actually i'm bringing a group up
from massachusetts that i worked with
when i was a director of a police
academy down there
and it is very very important that
we we have sound
uh instructors that are working
from uh the not only the police world
but also from the education world
with regard to that instructional design
person
i don't need somebody to be a law
enforcement person
to uh to fill that role of instructional
design
instructional design person i really
need them to be very strong in
curriculum
online content delivery
uh the forming of online training uh and
i
you know could i use more than one of
them yes i could
and and i you know i understand uh
that i have a fiduciary responsibility
and at the same time you know meet the
needs
and challenges that are before us uh in
our mission
uh but i i foresee that this
instructional design person would work
directly with each of the training
specialists to kind of be the rudder in
the water and help
each one of those trainers develop
high content make sure that learning
objectives are
clearly established that test questions
relate
directly to the learning objectives and
that if we do
case studies or scenario training
that is tied back into learning
objectives so that we can measure
we can clearly and objectively measure
competency
from when the the recruit officer first
enters the police academy uh
during their progress during the session
and then
uh measure their competency as they get
ready to graduate
and and i hope that answers your
question ma'am
representative heath you have a question
yes i do madam chair thank you and thank
you for taking my question
um i just i'm so pleased actually to
hear
um the additions that you're making
because i think sensitivity is so
critically important
covid has changed the way we're all
working
my question is kind of related to your
whole budget
and it relates to the the
funds that federal funds that are coming
into the state of new hampshire
within your budget um you know you've
talked about the changes that you need
to make
um that you've already incurred
in order to be able to reach those
to whom you're responsible are any of
these costs
things that can be charged back
to costs directly associated
with covid so that maybe there'd be some
federal reimbursement for some of these
things that you're
um including in your budget thank you
for taking my question
yes ma'am uh in fact um
my first day as the director of the
police academy was march 16th
and my first official act was to shut
the academy down
uh and and it's been uh it's been quite
a ride
uh since the beginning uh to that end
we were given very clear instructions
from the governor's office
as department heads to
track any costs incurred
that were directly related to
sustaining our mission uh
but uh where those expenses came in
because uh of
directly from cove at impact and so uh
we have been very uh very cognizant
and and uh have have kept track
of those costs to include you know we
had to buy some
um some flat screen tvs we had to kind
of uh
up our game with regard to uh zoom
subscriptions
uh uh there was uh some work done
for cleaning issues inside the building
so we have done everything we uh we can
in terms of tracking
uh those costs that are directly related
to covet response
and um and we continue to do that
i i don't know uh this is
uh clearly above my pay grade in terms
of of being able to speak to
maybe other opportunities and i i do not
know the answer to that question
but you know i certainly uh know people
who i could ask that could
maybe fill in that blank if that's
helpful
i i um representative
uh murray i i did fail to answer the
last piece of your question
uh you spoke directly to sensitivity
training and and um
implicit bias and and i do
i apologize for letting that one slip
uh i want everybody to know here that
uh even before uh
the leak commission began to meet
uh i worked uh very closely with
experts subject matter experts in the
area of
cultural diversity and we used uh
resources from the aclu we had the naacp
uh i had academics from the university
of new hampshire and from keene state
college
and uh that working group uh
put together a tremendous uh
implicit bias procedural justice class
uh that i'm very proud of the lin i had
a
particular training specialist who
oversaw the project uh
and and they really did an excellent job
and uh you know our uh
the response from the recruits uh we
just delivered the first block of
instruction this last class
and the recruits uh loved it in every
way
uh and the best part was the panel
discussion
uh and the biggest complaint was that
there wasn't enough time
for the panel discussion they want that
to be longer so
uh going to we're going to kind of
revisit that curriculum
but you know one of the things i think
that
is very important to recognize is that
there is a tremendous amount of talent
in the state of new hampshire
and using the university of new
hampshire using southern new hampshire
university granite state college
the technical college across the street
uh
we have excellent subject matter experts
to help us
in in developing high high value
uh content uh that is meaningful
and is uh and speaks to
uh the conditions and environment here
in our state
and i i have been very excited to work
with
uh all of those groups and i will
continue to work collaboratively with
those learning institutions and
and other other groups to help us make
sure that we're doing the very best job
that we can
so i i apologize for that representative
murray but i wanted
to address that representative murray
did you have a follow-up
um yeah just two quick things i was
gonna i would thank you for circling
back
i would have if you hadn't um
is it possible to sit in on some of
those sessions is there an audit
available are these zoom classes
or is that totally inappropriate so so
it
it uh it's an excellent question and one
that has been asked of me many many
times
since uh we've started to introduce some
of these classes
and uh you know i'm happy to share with
you
uh the uh the lesson plan if that's
helpful to you
you know one of the things that i am
most uh
fearful of candidly is that uh
you know the people who sit on this
panel uh
allow for for tough conversations to be
had
right and uh we we really are
encouraging
uh people to ask questions
uh and and and and get answers you know
and
uh you know some tough answers too right
and my fear is if we allow
people who are not part of that class
and i look at this i guess from an
educational point of view
i i don't want to have a chilling effect
where now all of a sudden i have these
young police recruits that
we're going to ask a question but oh my
goodness there's a representative from
the house of representatives in this
room so i
i'm not going to ask that question i've
had a lot of reporters ask the same
thing can we sit in on this class
and you you uh
you can only imagine how quiet
everybody's gonna get when there's a
reporter sitting there taking notes so
um and in
this isn't a hard no i i'm still trying
to figure out how we do it
i don't know uh if we allow uh
so that people aren't in the room and
maybe you
maybe you come to my office you know at
the academy and we can sit in my office
and we can zoom in on the class from
there kind of thing
i i'm i want to be open and transparent
and at the same time
my primary function responsibility is to
make sure that
what we're trying to get across during
this block of instruction and
every block of instruction is going to
have the highest value and the greatest
meaning to the recruit
so um but i and i'm happy to work with
you offline
uh if that would be helpful because i i
do want to figure out a way to do that
so understood thank you so much
representative bucco you have a question
uh yes thank you madam chair and thank
you mr skipper for coming today
um in this where you have the um
uh training specialist and instructional
design specialist is that just two
positions
those are two full-time positions that i
requested
uh the governor to to consider
and and he has supported those two
again and maybe i'll jump to um
uh i just wasn't sure if i heard two or
three but it's two
okay it is two it is true thank you
unless you wanted to make it three uh
[Laughter]
um thank you sir you're welcome sir
i think i was getting ready to talk
about food zero two one
um you'll see that there is a pretty
significant delta
on actual expenses versus the adjust
2021 adjusted or authorized and then
uh you'll see that the again the number
goes up a little bit
for 2223 and again
traditionally uh the way we deliver
the academy it is a 16-week
paramilitary residential environment and
uh i am a product of that environment
uh i graduated from the 88th session
uh and then i had the the privilege to
work as a training specialist
on the other end of the building for a
period of time during my career
and um and then managed that same kind
of delivery
system so uh you know now we're looking
at
pretty significant costs to maintain the
delivery system that we have now
and and there's a lot of value to to
continuing the way we do it and but
there's also
you know we have to ask ourselves some
hard questions and that is
can we do it a better way and can we do
it in a more fiscally responsible way
and can we leverage uh
maybe funds directed in one direction
maybe we can leverage those funds
to further augment training so
i i i kind of speak in generalities here
but
understand that that delta for food
institutions
speaks to the fact that we we did not
have a residential session
we have not had a residential session
since i've been here
because of covid and uh and that's why
you see those savings
you'll see that the number went up in
uh again we had to sign um a contract
with the with the sole food provider
uh so that we could be prepared uh in
the event
that we can kind of go back to our
old operation we're prepared to do that
so i anticipate uh based on kovid that
we're probably going to see some savings
during 22-23 um
if i might mr scipia do you
do you have a quote-unquote target date
for um getting back
to the classroom style of uh
learning yes uh yes we do
um one of the uh my i rely heavily
on uh the view and opinions of the
people that work for me
and the training staff came to me before
the session began in january
and expressed a lot of concern relative
to the surge
that was being anticipated uh and in
conjunction with the rollout of vaccines
and after discussion i made the decision
to
go to a completely remote uh
delivery system until such time as we
were
forced uh because of the fact that we
run out of
of lecture style classes uh we're gonna
push
all the skills development classes to
the back of the session
and uh we were hedging our bet
to to get vaccinations out uh
so that we could return as quickly as
possible so we're anticipating
uh and the the uh the date that that
we've kind of set on
is april 1 to begin
face-to-face in-service training again
still continuing
with all the safety measures screening
masks social distancing
but it is my opinion uh certainly my
staff i'm a little under the weather
right now i got my second
shot last night so i'm i'm kind of
plugging through here
um my staff has been vaccinated
vaccinated uh and a vast majority of the
police officers that we're going to have
in the building will have been
vaccinated and that
the hope is to get back operationally uh
to the way we used to be so we're
looking at april 1st
but clearly we need to maintain
flexibility
follow the directions from the
governor's office and the department of
of uh health uh just to to make sure
that we're
uh we're gonna keep people safe and
still still complete our mission
so we're staying flexible
uh if i could um i know that your
the majority of your training is for
brand new police officers
uh do they automatically get
the shot um i mean i
i know that uh you know first responders
and
police and so on have have that
opportunity but
the new recruits are they automatically
getting a shot or is that something we
can require them to have
before they attend the academy
it's uh that's the same thought process
process
that that i was using as well in terms
of
mandating that they get this shot before
they come back into the building
and i had the occasion to speak with the
ag's office on that
and you know ultimately uh because
you must be hired by an agency before
you can attend the police academy
they automatically are considered police
employees
and my understanding is that a vast
majority of those recruit officers
uh are receiving um or or they have the
opportunity to receive that vaccine
and from a continuity of operations
standpoint
and and it may sound a bit
uh selfish but uh
we i could not afford to have any of my
training people get sick
because there's there's so few of us
and and we are the sole source for
recruit training
uh i am confident now that once my staff
has
received the vaccines uh and we still
maintain those safety
measures uh we'll be able to continue
operations uh even if
uh people that are coming into the
building may or may not have received
that vaccine
so uh while while it
sounds i i hate the sound that you know
as far as working
we're safe so everybody's safe but from
from a pragmatic
point of view of continuity of operation
uh i think that we'll be good to go
as the surge comes through the vaccines
go up
and we still maintain those those safety
measures
thank you very much representative heath
you have a question
thank you madam chair um thank you for
taking my question
um to continue on with your um
discussion about the training
in the liat commission um a lot that
came out in that report that
our existing police force needs to be
updated could you just describe
the steps you're going to take to employ
some elements of the training and
particularly in the sensitivity um
and cultural awareness areas please
thank you
yes ma'am uh the uh
the governor's executive order 2020-1
uh the leak commission report
and the 2019 lba audit
are literally the road map that i will
be
following and and our organization will
be following
in the next couple of years uh
and and that's a good thing i think
because there's a clear direction that
our organization needs to move
right uh some of the mandated
uh training that has been identified and
uh set forth in that executive order
speaks directly to ethics
de-escalation uh
implicit bias and cultural diversity in
fact
the recommendations from leak and the
governor's order
mandate that every police officer in the
state of new hampshire
to maintain their certification must
annually complete
those three two hour blocks of
instruction
we have about four thousand police
officers in the state of new hampshire
and my training staff presently
is i believe it is eight people
deliver training we have to rely heavily
on volunteers
from agencies throughout the state to
help augment
our training efforts
to that end i clearly i understood that
in order to reach 4 000 people
annually we have
we have got to really build out our
online
in-service learning program uh because
the
candidly there would be no way for us to
complete that mission
uh with the with the staff that i have
there's just no way you know we
literally would be teaching
that that program every day throughout
the year
just to to keep up with those in-service
people
and that's just one one small piece of
training that we're ultimately
responsible for
further uh it's important to recognize
that the leak commission
and the governor's executive order uh
mandates
that the required number of hours of
in-service training
needed to be increased so presently we
have
eight hours of mandatory in-service
training
plus agencies are also required to
deliver
four hours annually of firearms and use
and then they have to qualify with their
firearm
we are moving from eight hours annually
all the way up to 24 hours annually
and so we've increased uh by way of leak
by way of the uh executive order uh and
candidly
it's it's the right thing to do it's
important and the right thing to do
to increase that mandatory in-service
training
uh continuous training is going to make
our excellent police officers even
better
uh but now you know
the load is significantly increased
with regard to the delivery of that
training the development of that
training
and so um you know my hope is
uh and again uh i'll i'll get to that
second line but ultimately i had
requested
uh from the governor uh his his support
for those two full-time positions that
i've already spoken to
and and again i was trying to be
financially responsible so
i asked for two part-time training
specialists
as well uh understanding that it would
be less expensive to hire
uh some part-time people to help augment
uh these efforts to to uh
to take care of this these these new
initiatives that have been um
uh given to us you know as an
organization
uh it's candidly i i
you know my hope is that uh these
increases that we're talking about here
today
are going to uh set the organization up
to be highly successful in the mission
uh you know i don't know i don't we have
to see how it goes now you know
we've been working in a covet
environment uh
we're trying to build the airplane while
we're flying it in some cases
uh there has been we had to develop a
new ethics program
a new uh you know de-escalation program
a new cultural diversity implicit bias
program
uh we have to increase scenario training
dramatically from where we're
at now which it was another leak
recommendation and mandate from
from the governor's office these are all
very important things that have to
happen
uh but
there's going to be a lot of heavy lift
that's going to come with that
uh something else that uh we're looking
at right now is
uh the last job task analysis
to measure core uh components
of a one to five year police officer
that job task analysis
has not been conducted in new hampshire
uh
for 20 years and we should be doing a
jta
about every five years just to make sure
that the curriculum that we're
delivering right now
speaks to the the core
competencies that a one to five year
police officer
needs to be able to to demonstrate when
they're out there working in their
communities
so once that job task analysis is
completed
i and i'm very excited i'm working with
the university of new hampshire's
justice studies department that is a
capstone project that
a graduate student is working on right
now along with the professors at unh
it is a very meaningful project to a unh
student it's saving the state's
significant amount of money
but we are on unh's scheduled now so
i i can't make it go any faster than
than the semester and i want i want the
student to be successful too
but after that jta comes out we now have
to do a complete
curriculum every single
block of instruction that we deliver
that makes up this curriculum
has now i now have to collect subject
matter experts from the state
this is what we do now here's the job
task analysis
what changes if any do we have to make
to be in line
with that jta that's going to be a huge
huge lift that's going to be a lot of
work
and i can't call a timeout
if i did not deliver an academy
one academy that would
significantly impact
the state of new hampshire uh and every
law enforcement agency that's trying to
fill open positions so that they can
police their communities
um so we have to i still have to keep
the plates
spinning over here and and then we have
some really
exciting challenges in front of us and
they really are exciting challenges but
there's going to be a lot of work
attached to it so my hope is
that the new training specialist the
instructional design person and then the
two part-time
training specialists um
will be able to uh really absorb uh
a lot of what we have going on uh
in the in the near near future in the
near future
uh so that we can we can address the the
components of the mission that's before
us now thank you
yes ma'am representative lynn you have a
question
uh you're on mute
so uh thank you madam chair uh uh mr
skip i i i guess
um from what you've said already my
understanding is
that most of the recruits that you get
as new officers are relatively young i
would
did presumably in their 20s or maybe
early 30s
yes sir and and i wonder if you could
just uh
tell me could you generally tell me what
would be the age or roughly the
you know the average age of your
instructors
so uh with with uh some
uh aberrancies here and there we're
probably averaging
uh recruit age is probably uh right
around
23 to 25 years of age uh we get a lot of
these
uh recruits who are uh military veterans
and or college graduates
and so that it puts them right around
you know that mark
we have some people who are are hired
literally uh you only have to be 18 to
be a police officer here in new
hampshire
and occasionally we'll get an 18 or 19
year old in there not not often but we
do
and then uh in this present session we
have people who um
you know had a career and have done
something uh for 20 years and then
they're jumping into police work
the candidly uh they're excellent people
to have in the
in the the room because they they
provide perspective
uh real world perspective with their
classmates
the training specialist average age of a
training specialist that i have here
and and instead of putting an age on it
time and service on it i generally have
people
that have 10 to 15 years
of law enforcement experience
on staff and and in those positions as
training specialists so
you're probably looking at people
between the ages of
35 to 50. so probably
uh you know probably 40 42 years old if
you're looking for one number on an
average um now it
i can tell you that that these people
that work as training specialists
uh are running a mile and a half in
about 10 minutes
and can do a hundred push-ups and
they're uh
they're in phenomenal shape and and
they're able to
uh clearly uh act as
excellent mentors and instructors in
those areas that they teach
um but they they are
about 10 to 15 years older than the
recruits that they're teaching
okay so so you may ask a follow-up uh
yes sir absolutely yeah so i guess what
really what what i mean what i was
where i was kind of going with these
questions is if the recruits
are very young and the instructors are
25 to 50 let's say and are in
you know as you just said generally in
excellent shape
i guess i'm i'm not it's not clear to me
why
you haven't resumed in person
uh instruction uh now
is in the same way that we're sort of
you know where we're
we we're trying to kick the the schools
uh in the fannie and excuse my excuse my
language but we're trying to kick the
schools and the fannies to get back to
in-person learning
um where there seems to be a lot of
reason to say that they could
i'm just wondering why you're not doing
that
you know sooner than you seem to be at
least and i guess i would understand
that
some of the physical training part the
you know
combat kind of training that kind of
thing i can understand where that might
involve
such close contact that you couldn't do
it but for the classroom part anyway
i'm kind of curious as to why you're not
you're not you know back in the class
now so to speak
so in uh an excellent question the last
session
that we just had that just graduated we
we did bring them back into the building
but we uh and and we tried to be as as
uh
close to operational as possible um
i i can't um part of
part of the the normal course of duty is
is uh
that they're assigned a room and a
roommate and they're using common
showers
common sinks they're sleeping in very
close proximity to each other
um as you spoke to representative lynn
uh you know a lot of the combat training
hand uh
defensive tactics training ground
fighting uh the exposure of oc
uh where literally they're they're
coughing and spitting and
and we gotta clean them up with hoses
and
you know water and stuff like that
they wear protective equipment when we
use simulation training so these are
closed masks
um clear masks uh
so we're trying to do the best we can
and at the same time
mitigate uh those kinds of situations
where
uh we're using gang showers or we have
them in close proximity you know
ultimately this session when it first
began
uh and with the with the information
that this
we were gonna get a pretty big surge
after
the holidays and into the winter months
and with the understanding that police
officers would be getting that
vaccination
it was my decision to go completely
remote
try to keep the building as quiet as
possible uh
get the staff vaccinated uh get through
the surge
make sure that the vaccination
availability
was such that the recruits would have an
opportunity to get vaccinated if they
wanted to
and uh that was the reason that i had
made that decision
uh believe me we we really do want to
get back to business
um when we had the last class in
uh our facility uh
is is not equipped
to seat the number of people we have to
see
in a room to begin with on a good day we
have people
right on top of each other to maintain
social distancing
we literally had to use two different
lecture halls
and we had to zoom the lecture
from one room into the other room and
then the instructors would walk
up and down the hallway to just check on
the two different groups
were we able to do it yes we were um
you know best case scenario no it was
not it hasn't been best case scenario
since i've been here so
uh but we we are definitely working
towards
trying to get back to that
normalcy whatever that might be great
all right thank you very much yes sure
are there any further questions from mr
scipia
uh i i do have a question for uh is it
miss
ames who is on your uh board
yes i i promised her that she wouldn't
have to answer but i think she's going
i'm here hi laura lee yeah thank you
miss ames
um how long have you been on
the uh police standards and training
board
uh i've been employed here since 1994.
okay okay all right
and madam chair she uh she is kind of my
uh my business agent and my hr person
uh she she's actually the real director
of the police academy but we're not
going to admit that so
you never you never should but i i know
i know from where you come
so are are you happy
with the um people that are currently
i'm not i'm not talking about the staff
i'm talking about
what what's it called the police
standards and training
advisory council representative umberger
uh ms ames is is a state employee she's
with the
um police standards in training council
the agency she's not a counselor i don't
believe on the council
no i'm on staff yeah yeah i understand
that but
how about mr scabia would you like to
comment on that
i uh there um literally
has been um a
uh change in the membership of the
council
uh and and in fact next week we have our
first council meeting with the new
counselors
uh that have just been appointed by the
governor uh
i certainly can speak to uh the members
of the council
uh that i have worked with since i've
been here
and i can also comment on on the
counselors that have been newly
appointed
uh at every turn that every turn
since i have been here uh i have
received
uh tremendous support from the members
of the council
each one of those members of the council
recognize wholeheartedly
the importance of their position and the
gravity of the decisions that they make
they hold me accountable and i like that
and uh they specifically
uh will provide guidance direction and
answer
questions anytime i need those types of
things
and i have had uh just an excellent
relationship
uh both personally and professionally
with the members of the council
when i first came in uh there's a lot of
new members uh that are coming in
uh with the exception i think of one uh
new member i am familiar
with all of the new appointees i hold
them
in equal regard and i look forward to
working with them i think that um
you know at the end of the day uh new
hampshire law enforcement
you know collectively understands the
importance
of the mission of our agency and uh
every person that uh is appointed to
that board
uh fully supports our operation and uh
they've just been excellent to work with
and and um very support i can't say
enough good things
and not because i got an answer to them
they're just they're good people to work
with
i i got that uh representative bucco you
yes thank you madam chair um so
one of the big advantages that that all
um all the municipal police departments
uh have centralized this centralized
training
and but one of the big incentives is
that they send their offices at no cost
is that does that remain is that going
to remain that way
see uh representative buko i can tell
you unequivocally that i have worked in
two different environments uh police
training environments i was a director
of a police academy in massachusetts i
was
i was one of probably 15 police
academies across the commonwealth
and at every director's meeting that i
would go to they would always point
north and say we should be doing what
new hampshire is doing
we have to do what new hampshire is
doing uh
in massachusetts it's a tuition-based
program in other words the
the police agencies and or the student
themselves
have to pay a a tuition now it's a
it's a very modest tuition and it
clearly does not cover the cost of
the the academy um
presently and and traditionally since
its inception uh the state has
recognized
here in new hampshire that it's the
responsibility of the state to make sure
that our police officers are trained
appropriately and i think that's that's
always kind of been the vision the way i
understand it
is that this is a a governmental
responsibility it's a public safety
responsibility and then the state
uh accepts that responsibility is there
alternative ways that we could fund this
i imagine there are uh i think that uh
you know we should we should always be
forward leaning we should always try to
you know figure out is there a better
way to do this is there is there a
better way to cover the cost of this
are there public private partnerships
that that we can start to develop
can we charge tuition uh you know these
are all
discussion points that really need to be
thoughtfully covered um
i i would say you know never say no to
anything let's talk about it let's
figure out if this is going to be
you know a workable way to to help you
know offset these
these costs that are in front of us
absolutely
thank you representative murray you have
a question
thank you madam chair thank you very
much uh mr skip has been fabulous
talking with you i have three
questions particular to the budget one
is if there was one thing you could
change in the budget what would it be
and two is there something missing is
there a blue sky thing that you would
love i'm always optimistic about budgets
so is there one thing you would love to
see that's not there and just generally
are you happy
let me answer let me answer the last
question first
uh i i um i have been involved in new
hampshire law enforcement now for 32
years
uh i i can't tell you how happy i am to
have
the job that i have right now and uh
and i'm excited i i am significantly
excited
about the challenges that are in front
of us right now and i tell my staff all
the time
these aren't things we have to do these
are things we get to do
we are going to be uh making
uh such a tremendous difference for the
citizens and the visitors of our state
so i'm very happy to be here and very
excited to be here
uh to to speak to
you know if i could
increase the staff uh that
my my staff uh
god bless every one of them they are
uh they work hard every single day and
the responsibilities that they have
are are far-reaching they teach uh
recruit classes they have to uh
you know maintain their welfare of these
recruits they have to make sure they get
fed uh that they go through fitness
training
they're delivering uh classes but then
we also have
the the in-service component we have to
teach uh
in-service classes we have to write
curriculum
we have to put together facilitators
guides
i have a bureau commander who's
literally
uh along with his staff putting together
uh a brand new record management system
and learning management system
uh they are uh they're working really
hard and if i had
the ability to snap my fingers and and
you know double the size of
of the staff here uh we could get
significant things done that is not a
fiscally responsible thing for me to ask
for
and uh and i would not ask for that um
because i'm really happy with my job and
i don't want to lose it
uh but you know to that end um uh
i i think my my staff uh at least when
i'm around
they they share the same optimism and
and excitement that i do
uh they know they're working hard uh
they know i'm in here trying to help
them
get the resources that they need and um
you know i i think you know at the end
of the day
we are a service provider much like any
other police department quite frankly
and the services that we provide uh
are so vitally important because we are
literally training every police officer
in the state
to then go back to their communities and
protect and serve
the people who live in those towns so uh
and cities and and
on the highways and and out in the woods
you know uh so
it's uh the actions of my staff
and my organization are are far-reaching
and and vitally important to our state
so i uh if i could get more help it
would be awesome
but we will do the best we can with what
we got
and we do a pretty darn good job right
now so
just gotta hit the right button uh thank
you madam chair
uh thank you for taking my question mr
shipra how do you measure
the effectiveness of your program
say from five years ago to today and
what we need to do
because i believe that we have probably
the greatest
law enforcement people uh in the country
um that state police local police
very very few people are very you know
you hear very few stories is it is it
the amount of lawsuits we get or
or what how do you measure that
sir i i concur with your opinion
wholeheartedly
i think we do an excellent job here in
new hampshire new hampshire law
enforcement i
i don't think that uh i think we
collectively hold ourselves to a very
high standard and we may
make sure that that standard is carried
across the board with regard to
uh measuring uh
you know are are we doing the right
thing are we are we
providing the right training to to make
sure that these officers are going to be
competent and professional when they
when they leave the academy i i'm really
leaning hard on that job task analysis
which hasn't been done in a little while
now we are fortunate that we're a
smaller state we have some
very forward-leaning police chiefs
uh the colonel of state police uh you
know these people
are very uh forward looking forward
leaning people
uh when they lead their agencies and and
working with those
with those uh peers that i have
uh i i think you know despite or
notwithstanding the fact that we've
we've been kind of uh i don't know
delinquent and not doing that jta
i still feel very confident working with
with my peers that we're able to to
still
uh keep that high level of police
services
uh going uh here in the state to to
to put a measure on it we're going to
need to do that jta
and then i'm going to need to sit down
and get those subject matter experts in
here and make sure that we're
we're leading the way here uh in new
hampshire
you know one of the things uh and to
your point sir
we are only one of two states in the
country
that offers at a state level
active bystandership in law enforcement
training
i've committed the state of new
hampshire to this program
uh this program empowers uh police
officers to be able to step in and
prevent misconduct
uh and and to build a stronger community
trust
and um we have new hampshire on
on the east coast and we have the state
of washington is the only other state
uh in the country that is has accepted
this
at a state level so um we're doing the
we're really trying to to you know stay
in front of and be an example for
uh new uh law enforcement all right uh
follow up
uh madam chair um yeah um i had training
uh
matter of fact over 50 years ago and the
big thing was common sense
that's what the chief told and that was
it he said common sense and actually
uh i have a meeting tonight with the
daughter of one of the first graduates
of the
academy so which is which is kind of
neat
i didn't realize it went that went by
that fast 50 years
yes i and and you know to your point
um common sense and treat people with
respect you
you can teach the academy in about you
know two days
and and just treat people nice
do the best you can to help them and use
common sense and that
that is if you don't have those things
you probably shouldn't be a cop
not in new hampshire thank you very much
yes sir
uh i do have one one further question
if i might uh are you training
correction officers at this time
yes ma'am we are and um uh that is one
of our
missions not only do we run a full-time
police academy in a part-time police
academy
but we also oversee the
department of corrections corrections
academy and
i know that commissioner hanks i work
very closely with commissioner
hanks uh you know
we we we want to make sure that we're uh
we're addressing
the needs of the department of
corrections as well uh we have uh
an excellent uh commandant at police
engine training that oversees the
program
and some real excellent uh corrections
trainers
that come from the department of
corrections to put that academy staff
together
uh we actually are in session right now
with a full-time academy
a part-time academy and a corrections
academy as we speak
so all three of those are in session
thank you very much are there any
members of the committee and madam chair
if i could speak to just one more item
just to
to uh make sure that it's it's spoken to
if if i could ask you to go to 1301 page
at the very bottom you're gonna see line
one
zero two and that is
uh contracts for program services
and this is a new line item
and you'll see that it goes from zero to
uh over the biennium
two hundred thousand dollars and this
money
um has been added
through the governor's budget after
consultation with leak
after consultation with director ken
norton of new hampshire nami
and this money is specifically set aside
to train police officers to respond
to events where people are
suffering from a mental health crisis
you know all too often uh and this is
not just in new hampshire but nationally
uh the police are called oftentimes
because
people don't know who else to call and
uh the police are called
to an event where somebody is suffering
from a a mental health crisis and in
fact
uh their aberrant behavior may uh
may necessitate a use of force
and um you know we understand that
uh it is vitally important for police
officers to have
uh a level of training so that they can
interact
effectively with people who are in
crisis
so that we can try to de-escalate
the issue in the first instance take
them into custody in a safer way with
maybe
not using uh a level of force that
is justified but is there a better way
to do this right
and and um you know to that end i i work
very closely with director norton
and um you know he he's spoken to me
about
jesus or any way that we can we really
want police standards and training to
start delivering this
this product and this training uh
i i think it's very important and i
think it's important not only to the
communities that we serve honest to
goodness it's important for the police
officers to have these tools too because
the police officers have to carry with
them uh
the results of of those actions that
they take and
and if there's a way that we can
protect the mental health of the officer
on top of that
and and allow them an opportunity to
to maybe take on a an issue
in a different manner a different way
based on this new training
then um it's better for the community
it's better for the officer the outcomes
are just better
so i i i did want to speak to that
directly because
you know this is it's kind of a special
earmark i think it's important
it is expensive but i think it's very
important and in the end it serves
the citizens of our state so
and and madam chair i i stand ready for
any
any further questions otherwise that
would that would conclude my
presentation
okay thank you thank you very much i
hope you noticed that we were pretty
kind
thank you i appreciate that anytime um
i do want to ask is there anyone that
has
not been over to the police standards
and training
area
okay it looks like everybody has done
that at
some time or other and it's always an
eye-opening experience
for um the people the representatives to
actually see what
uh what goes on over there and um
and i you know i i thank the people at
the academy for putting up with us when
we uh
when we do come so all right if there no
if there are no further questions thank
you very much for
uh for being with us today and um
i think all of the questions have
we will not be voting on your budget
today but
i don't think that there's from my
perspective anyhow
that there is anything in here that we
would
have significant questions about so
i thank you and good luck in your new
job
madam chair and members uh thank you so
much for your time
and uh i stand ready if there's any
follow-up questions later on if you want
to reach out to me
i i would be you know happy to try to
help answer or clarify anything
and please stop by it'd be nice to you
know meet people face to face and i'm
very proud about our operations i
love to even if you've had a tour we'll
we'll give you another one so
uh thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen i appreciate your time
thank you so much um
i have about 11 15
and we have lottery coming in at 11 30.
so um get up stretch
do whatever you need to do and we'll
we'll see you back um
mickey do we want to leave this open
or do we want to close it and come back
or what
that's up to you we we've got this set
up as a reoccurring
webinar so i can close it and open it
back up anytime and you just click your
same links to come in
it's really whatever you want to do
whatever the committee wants well as
long as it can stay open let's just
leave it open
and we'll do whatever we need to do by
the way
we also need to introduce andrea that's
right yes
who has uh appeared on the screen but
uh she's she's new to us so if you would
i'll let andrea introduce herself but
basically she's a performance auditor
with the lba audit division and she's
going to be helping us out this session
uh as normal we have uh
audit helpers and and she's been
assigned to help with division two
matters this year but andrea i don't
know if you want to tell a little bit
about the work you've done and how long
there we go can everyone hear me now
good afternoon representatives um i
think mickey well explained
um a little bit of my background been
with the office for about four years now
and i work in the
audit division doing performance audits
uh
division two is a lot of different
agencies that i actually haven't worked
on yet so i'm actually really excited
um to get some exposure to education
and police and training standards and
lottery which i have not worked on
not really much more to it um i did work
on the parole board audit that was one
big audit that i was on
so i guess that kind of speaks to a
little bit of my time there
thank you for having me thank you and uh
welcome
to uh division two thank you
mickey will be a great teacher no
question about it no pressure he has
so you want to keep the meeting open
representative
pardon want to keep the the zoom webinar
live i'll just put up a shared screen
just letting the public know that we'll
be
uh getting back together at 11 30.
uh
it uh looks like we're all back
and um i see that mr mcintyre has
i have pretty close to 11 30. so
mickey if you would uh bring mr mcintyre
back up
or up and uh then i think we can
uh proceed welcome mr mcintyre
good to see you again uh madam chair i'm
burger how are you
i'm good i'm good yourself very well
thank you very well good to see all the
members of the committee as well and
with me
also is our chief financial officer uh
jim duress who has led into the meeting
as well
would love you to start yes please okay
certainly um if i
i'll be sharing a screen briefly um
if i can do that and not screw it up um
obviously
um i wanted to give a just a brief
background
uh to the members of the division on the
lottery uh and its revenue
as you obviously are aware the lottery
is a
revenue agency and an enterprise account
uh and the budget process while we're
subject to the budget process
uh the legislature doesn't actually
appropriate any funds for us
we spend from our own revenue stream and
and are self-funded
and so um for us we really as you can
imagine focus on the revenue side
while obviously keeping track of the
expense side so i wanted to run through
so this is our sales of games
by the last 10 years obviously the
takeaway from this slide is that the
majority of what we sell in stores
and the majority of our revenues come
from scratch tickets
over the last 10 years over two billion
dollars in sales of them
um right now our second biggest selling
product is probably keno
uh right now it's averaging over a
million dollars a week
in sales which is in excess of what we
had estimated originally
this slide is a breakdown of our
revenues
by fiscal year for the last 15 years
obviously we are very proud of the fact
that that number keeps going up
and not down and this is just our the
gross number which is
an interesting number but certainly not
the most important one um
this is our scratch ticket sales which
is something we can control and have
been
actively promoting as our biggest
product
it also has been growing over the last
this is the graph for powerball and mega
millions
what this slide really is meant to
demonstrate is that the revenues of
these two products which
constitute a significant portion of our
sales are erratic
because they are jackpot driven and so
as a result
jackpots drive sales 2020 as you will
see
was a very off year for that we did not
have any large jackpots
which thankfully we had this year we
just in january had a very very
good month and two significant jackpots
which helped
drive revenue um
this is kino sales obviously it's a new
product but it has been growing
uh 2020 as you can imagine we were faced
with a problem
in that when bars and taverns were shut
down so was kino sales so
really march through june we in uh 2020
were
sales were minimal uh but this year
sales ever bounded
dramatically uh and as i suggested we're
doing
on average now a million dollars a week
and so we expect it to continue to grow
uh and this is the important slide uh
and our last one
this is what our distributions education
have been over the last 15 years
and what they're projected to be this
year as well as the out two years
um and as you
obviously we're very proud of the fact
that the last 10 years we've essentially
doubled sales
and doubled net profitability in
education um so those
were the slides i had for you um uh
chair umberger i don't know if you want
any members who want any questions
regarding slides or revenues
or want to sort of go into uh our
expenses
i am oh representative murray you have a
question
thank you madam cherry i have another
question um where
in this state do people typically play
keno is it
distributed across the state is it more
in the southern tier is it in the north
country where
are these bars and restaurants that
provide keno
um it's across the state in varied
locations
mostly concentrated in the south and
sort of
south central it's really the bulk of
our sales come from rocky and
millsborough county
but that's true of all of our sales i
mean our 60
of our revenues come from rocky and
hillsborough county because there's a
lot of folks that live there
as you can imagine uh and lottery sales
one of the key variables is population
density
because if you live in the north country
you may drive by a store once every few
days
if you live in manchester you drive by a
store you know 10 a day
and so your access to avail to stores
that sell our stuff
and you know bars being located
generally in large population density
areas
that's where most of our sales are
follow-up if i may
please thank you um i don't suppose you
have any sense of
out-of-state versus in-state people who
play
uh actually oddly it's a good question
in the process
now of pulling that data really the best
way to
do that is to look at the cash
the winning tickets that have been
cashed and the state of residence for
the winning tickets
um folks tend to play where they work
not
where they live um and
there are towns that actually don't have
a store but they're still folks that
play there
so we're in the process of looking at
that now
i do know we saw an increase in revenues
particularly around the lakes region
during coven because i think a lot of
folks have moved up there
who had summer homes um from
massachusetts
uh also for sports betting for us we
see about 12 of our revenues come from
massachusetts on the sports betting
mobile platform
and i believe the majority of our
revenues
in the physical locations in seabrook
and manchester are from massachusetts
thank you representative heath you have
a question
thank you madam chair i think it's been
answered my question was
with regard to the sports betting and
how that's going
and and um for
the year what did um revenue look like
from that
actually um thank you for
congratulations i actually have
just today the new financials as of
january i can show them if you'd like
i would like to see that thank you oh
wrong one
can you can you see the screen where it
shows new hampshire lottery new
hampshire
sports book revenue yes
so if you go to the far right section
it'll say combined
um handle which is a column to the
the far right block but the far left
column it says handle
that is the amount of money that's
wagered so if you and i bet 50
on the patriots me to lose you to win
that would be 100
of handle even though really my 50 went
to you because you won and i lost
gross gaming revenue is the amount left
over after all of the people who have
won have been paid
and state rev share is the amount each
month that the state receives in revenue
from sports betting
so if you go down to the bottom uh this
fiscal year
we've handle has been 285 million
dollars
gross gaming revenue has been 22 million
and the state's share
thus far has been 10.5 million
which is significantly better than we
had anticipated when we made their first
revenue estimates
um way back when
thank you that's exactly what i was
looking for okay
honestly it was just prepared finished
today by our cfo and i was just looking
at it
before this meeting started so wonderful
obviously the the revenue
is going very well and um and that's
that's great for the education trust
fund we're we're excited about that
yes and actually to that point uh madam
chair we um
our plan was for 110 million and we
raised guidance with ways and means in
the governor's office
120 million for this fiscal year
and so that's obviously helping in terms
of the budget issues we had
and we have seen like i said we've seen
an influx of revenues
well over and above our comparator
states
like maine and vermont and i think a
large portion has been
influx of citizens who are playing up
here now mass citizens i mean
uh can you tell me how um
historical horse racing went in ways and
means
um it went okay i think uh obviously
a hearing where i think 180 people
signed up
um is tough in this times i think
they're gonna
have a couple of work sessions going
forward um
and i think it went okay um other your
colleagues obviously could tell you
differently but um i think it went fine
certainly for us it's i mean i i think
we've made the case a number of times
that
um for us it's how far do you want us to
be on the dial of gambling and we'll
happen to be there and do the best we
can
we don't really sort of support or
oppose legislation like that because
it's a policy decision
i often say that we don't make policy
with the instruments of policy
you tell us what to do and we try to do
go ahead representative heath thank you
i forget sometimes to
technology-wise to raise my hand but my
hand automatically goes up
um a question um with regard to
historical racing
um that's something we've been talking
about now for uh
a few years um what would your
projection
be in fact if we were to
um uh adopt historical racing
so um i made revenue estimates um uh
potential is a fiscal note attached to
the bill
uh if i recall i don't have it in front
of me i think that charities would
realize an additional 5 million
and the state would realize an
additional i think it was 13 million
but certainly those numbers are fluid in
the sense of it's your call as to how
much you want each side to get if you
want the state to get more or less
you know that number is not really tied
to anything here it's just the way the
bill was drafted
and our revenue estimates they're from
um if the charities
want to get more and more less than
that's or you want
to take it all it's your call all right
sorry about being sure you got cut
uh representative uh he did you have a
follow-up question
i do um and i apologize um
thank you so much uh for taking this
question
um in terms of charitable gaming um
there are um there's oversight for that
purpose and i know that there was um
some kind of a study done
that um recommended the number of people
um
to really oversee charitable gaming um
is that your department or do you know
nothing about that
it's my department representative um
that was merged
it wasn't originally but in 2016-17
the governor put into her budget
governor hassan and it was approved by
you folks
the the absorption of charitable
how many people do you have overseeing
uh charitable gaming
um in some cases there's some people do
it part-time
like our cfo does the numbers obviously
he does all of our math
in his department um but directly
it's approximately 11. so they're 10 or
11 people to oversee childhood gambling
um there's three investigators we're
hiring there's
a fourth investigator hiring a fifth
we have five financial auditors um
which is significantly more than we have
when we absorb the agency i think
at the time they'll have one uh so we
have significantly greater oversight
than we ever had before
uh if that's your question
representative yes thank you very much
i will i will just comment that um
i was involved in one of the charitable
gaming
sessions and um
the state does a a very good job in
making sure
that both the charity and
the operator uh are um
are are good you can't you can't just
uh say well yeah let's do that tomorrow
so it's
uh they're doing a in my opinion anyhow
a very good
job uh with the charitable gaming
so representative bucco you had your
i did my question was asked and answered
okay um where's the macintosh
representative yeah
mr mcintyre uh yeah
whatever you're sure you don't want to
run for state rep
um i know i know
uh do you want to go through your
certainly um happy to do it the um
this year our you'll see our expenses
are
significantly larger than they were last
year um
in a couple of areas one obviously is
personal services we did hire a few more
people
because we have been growing as you can
see um
growth comes with a cost right and so
one of the things i'd like to sort of
point out is
the net profit on the slide that's up on
the screen that's our last slide
is net of expenses and so that growth
is these expenses are netted out of that
profit and so
you know as we grow more we have to
spend more
um there's a couple of expenses which
look odd and i'll go through
um one is um
current expenses which in this fiscal
year is 682
and drops down to 402 uh
in 405 and 2022 and 2023
that was in place to essentially pay for
our own hosting of sports betting if
indeed we were going to do that
which we didn't end up doing so um even
though that
figure is 682 we won't spend anywhere
near it
because we weren't sure if we were going
to be the hosting entity for sports
betting
meaning we had to build out a server
room and nice and uh
internal control which we did not have
to do or the expenses that went with it
as well as sort of the support that goes
with it um
because of our partnership with
draftkings they really handle all the
expenses there
um and so forth so as a result
we don't need to spend as much money um
the request
out years 402 500 and then 405 500
current expenses pays for a number of
expenses
one of which is obviously that the lba
audit bill we pay which is about 75 000
annually
comes out of that fund um what we pay
for to support the retail network all
the point of sale materials we send out
is paid from that
line item uh and so it's a big expense
for us but certainly it's an important
one because it supports our retail
network
um transfers to oit is certainly
their number what it what we think what
they think they're going to spend
supporting us it's obviously a fluid
number depending on what our needs are
um i don't know
whether whether expense sort of
promotion i know is a big item
if you'll see in 2020 we only spent
2.068 million and this year we
prospect projected to spend 2.5 and the
reason for that i'll relate back to the
slide
a few ago where i showed you powerball
and megan millions being very low
in 20. that's due to low jackpots
and we don't promote low jackpots
because it's not worth it
and so we spend when the jackpots at 300
million and 400 million dollars
we spent a lot of money on tv and radio
promoting those jackpots
because we see a return of a significant
return on investment
it's like ten to one but if there's not
we don't spend it and therefore it
lapses
and obviously if we don't spend it
it lapses because our revenues
are net of expenses so if it doesn't get
spent it's a
profit education and those are set by
the terms of actually the constitution
that formula is in
second part article six b of the state
constitution
and so um i'd like to think
uh and i'll use this analogy i like to
think we act like grown-ups when it
comes to our budget
um we never generally spend up to the
budget only because if we don't need to
we don't spend it
like 2020 we only spent 9.25 million
dollars
despite being authorized for a
significantly higher number
and so in some cases these are here just
in case we
we need to spend it and want to capture
every other revenues we can
um and i know there's another um jim you
want to talk about our prioritized
request
sure excuse me um
so our original um our original budget
that we submitted for doit expense
uh we had additional prioritized
requests in there for
a cnr crm system uh
which is a bit large project so we we
actually originally budgeted
513 000 with an additional 220 000
i'm rounding off for the crm project
going forward over the next few years
this is a plan that our sales team put
together in order to
better gather information about our
customer base
responses information we receive and
request for information we receive
to try to streamline our systems
so the governor did add it into our
into the governor's recommended budget
which our sales team was very happy
about
and if i could sort of add color to that
um
we've added multiple new channels to our
offerings
so for example we have an internet
lottery program
and that those customers come through us
from one
method we have the draftkings sports
betting platform
those calls come to us for another
method obviously we have our traditional
lottery
those calls come into us and then now we
have keno and those calls come into us
so we're not doing a very good job of
tracking our customers who call in
and making sure they get response times
as fast as we would like them to
and so that's really what the priority
the request is for
is to make sure we're servicing the
folks who quite literally pay our
salaries
um well and making sure nobody's
falls to the cracks the you know the i
didn't get a call back drives me insane
if i hear that so
um i want to make sure we don't slip and
fall on that
and i'm happy to answer any questions
anyone has on our budget it's a pretty
straightforward little budget i think
thankfully there's no no grants no
no federal money there's just i always
get those emails i'm like i i just
literally it's from sales it's from the
sale of tickets
i uh i did i did have a question um
i noticed that your uh
done something different there
jim those numbers are provided to us
from das
um i can tell you that our original
amount for the year
i'm trying to zoom to it here bear with
me
um our original amount for the year was
actually that we originally requested
was actually higher for 2022
and it was decreased on the governor's
version
um and the same or excuse me and the
exact opposite for 2023. so those are
numbers provided
by das nothing that we calculate here
same as with salaries it would roll
right along with salary figures through
okay i guess i i i knew that i should
have
not said that yeah i'm assuming they
made an adjustment in some way on their
end of how they're handling things
sort of like we've seen opeb and
everything we've seen adjustments there
over the last couple years because of
changes they've made
so that's my assumption yeah because of
our actual absorption of racing we
picked up
all the racing employees who had retired
previously as well so that had jumped up
and you said that with the
doit transfer it's because of a
a new system that you're implementing
yes it's um it's called crm which
stands for customer relationship
management tool it's an ability for
essentially software to track
all of our relationships and all of the
calls and emails we receive from
customers
of which as you can imagine we receive a
lot
it also allows you to uh data mine to
gather data and to create reports and
and analyze things so that you have a
okay i see a couple of hands and i'm
sorry i don't know who was first
representative heath thank you madam
chair and
um thank you for taking my question i
live in manchester
uh manchester uh we have a lot of
terrible game going on in my city and
keno seems to be quite a hit do you have
any um figures or do i need to wait for
the crm system to come on board
before you can tell me exactly how much
money do you think the city of
manchester
drives for the state of new hampshire um
i can find that out for you i don't have
the number on right now
because i don't have it broken up by
city uh obviously as you can imagine
manchester being a large largest in the
state
but also a commercial base as well
is probably larger than its population
in terms of revenue growth
revenue from the lottery um
but i'd have to get them before you're
presented i'm happy to do it it just
will take a little bit
representative murray you have a
question oh thank you madam chair i
should have lowered my hand you asked
the question that i was going to ask
so i'm good what do they say
great minds think alike is that right
there you go
are there um any further questions
for uh mr mcintyre
uh uh i'll call you charlie i'm sorry
that i can't get keno
passed in conway it's uh it's absolutely
a losing cause
and it must be because representative
i enjoy the drive anyway representative
bomber i enjoy the drive up every time
uh it's one of the places i actually
personally make sure i go to
um it would be great especially now
during ski season the bars would be
well whatever i appreciate the effort
well hopefully we can uh wait a couple
three years and see what happens but
representative bucco it seems like you
want to say something
well i just wanted to can you am i yeah
i just wanted to respond to that
remark that i i was out there trying to
yeah i think last time they got in with
the bathwater in terms of
other issues yeah i don't understand it
either but certainly obviously
i saw the first initial fear for kino i
get it folks who are reluctant to vote
for it
but we haven't had so much as a single
call related to a problem with it in
terms of
any issue at a bar or tavern and most of
the bars that have it love it
and we did a study after the fact that
i've used a couple of times in
presentations
the all of the bars saw a lift between
five to twenty five percent
in their other stuff yeah so they sold
more food they sold another beverage and
dessert
so um one of the bar owners put it to me
like
it was the first time i thought the
state did something for me versus you
know
so um bringing in a million dollars a
week it
makes a big difference too originally it
was only about eight or nine million
yeah no so you know we had estimated 40
million when we first did evidence
revenue estimates and now it's going to
be like 50
million at least uh it's continuing to
accelerate so
like i said we're seeing it most along
the border
and then the bigger cities as you can
imagine
and one of the things it does actually
is it makes the bar more valuable if you
wanted to sell it
right
okay are there any further questions for
mr mcintyre yes go ahead represent me
thank you um i just have to ask this
question in terms of um
problem gambling uh are are you seeing
um or do you know or can you identify um
an increase in problem gambling based on
the covet pandemic and all the offerings
that we have now available to
the state certainly um
there's a council of problem gaming that
tracks data
we don't as a matter we're the funding
source
um one of the nice things is because the
technology the
both the sports betting platform as well
as our internet platform
both have tools which allow the player
to help themselves
in essence to either limit the amount
they spend as well as
exclude themselves we have hundreds and
hundreds of people who have excluded
themselves both from sports betting
and internet um that we don't have the
ability to do at a store
um you know if that makes sense stopping
somebody from buying a lottery ticket is
the equivalent of stopping somebody
buying a cup of coffee statewide which
is not possible so
you know technology allows us to do that
representative murray thank you madam
chair can you speak to kino and the
places that have in the places that
don't have it
does this get revisited are there
communities that don't have it that it
comes back up for another vote
and have there been communities that
have decided they don't want it anymore
there were places that initially really
wanted it very badly
and where uh the sponsors were bars in
towns and cities that really wanted to
have it and those were really along the
mass border because mass has
keno and the biggest locations for kino
in massachusetts and coincidentally in
north america
are on the mass new hampshire border
three of the top five in north america
are on the board
so bars they're really excited to get it
as you can imagine so they were really
first jumped to it
and and then there were places which
were unsure
didn't vote for the first time and voted
for the second time
and then there are places where it will
never happen and to the end of time
as long you know just won't happen um
so you know i never say never never say
always but
i would be support there's certain like
portsmouth for example has been dead set
against it
since it it started so um
i because we've hit our revenue target i
stopped really going out and soliciting
the vote we never really campaigned for
it like you would like you folks do
um we just would go out and answer
questions at the town meetings
i saw a few obviously a bunch of folks
in your towns
and cities um but no we
there's no i don't think there are any
cities or towns that have on the ballots
coming this fall
are there any places that have it and
decided it was a bad idea
no no
and honestly i i haven't heard even like
a selectmen or
are there any further questions that
right seeing nothing i'm sorry i did not
sorry okay no problem i've got this
little white hand at your head so
um
so um if there are no further questions
area that's coming in is uh fish and
game at 1
30. and so um
we'll have a opportunity for lunch thank
you
mr mcintyre for giving us that
and um we will
come back together at 1 30
and uh mickey i assume that
we probably should sign off
and um yeah i think considering it's
you know 90 minutes i'll probably shut
down the webinar and then just start it
back up again
probably around 125 and everyone can
re-enter
again do we
have to do we have to show something
that says we're in recess
until 1 30. that's up to you i mean it's
uh we can figure out something
it's just it occupies the screen for um
90 minutes now that i've got to keep the
my computer kind of shared screen but i
can do that if you want i know
other committees have been doing that um
i don't know if
it's a rule of the house that that you
have to keep the webinar open
or if we can just you know end it and
then restart it again i think it's
really up to you
whatever you'd like to do i don't
i don't have any idea no one has uh i
mean
considering you've got a fishing game
posted at 1 30
the public will know you're getting back
together at 1 30. i think if there was
an open-ended recess like if you took a
break
until you know i could put something on
the screen that says is currently in
recess
because it's unknown when you're coming
back um so it's up to you i mean i can
put it like an away message up now that
says division 2 is in recess
until fishing game at 1 30. if you'd
like that just in case anyone pops in
um i'm not expecting folks too we have
uh two two attendees right now and one
of them is janet and she knows what
we're up to
so um i don't think there's gonna be
many
folks in the public looking for division
two in the next 90 minutes so
okay i think that's probably the best
thing and we'll uh
we'll come back about uh 125 and uh
hope everyone has a a good lunch
and we'll see you then oh
yes representative murray mickey do you
think we can get charlie's slides i
think he's already gone i wanted to ask
if he could email us his slides
i emailed him to you this morning so you
should you did
and then just a reminder on on our lba
page we do have that division two
so anything that i get handouts
presentations throughout this session
i'm gonna throw them right online so
you and you know sort them
chronologically so you'll be able to
refer back if you can't put your hands
on something
yeah i got police standards but i've met
i don't have a lot actually lottery may
have come yesterday i think i sent a
lottery to you yesterday
all right i'll find it thank you
representative lynn you have a question
yes you know i just want to make sure
that i'm i'm
performing my duties as clerk as i'm
supposed to be so
the first question the first question i
have is um
i i got from the from clerk smith
two forms to be used that where you know
one of them
the one which i thought was the one for
attendance
but as i look at it more closely it it
really seems to be
a form that's to be used if we're
actually voting on some particular bill
and so i'm wondering is there another
form that i don't have that you use to
uh mickey do you wanna i think it's just
the uh
there's just one form for taking
attendance
and normally janet should give you or
somebody should give you the um
the sheets for voting okay
i do have i think i do have the sheet
for voting but i i
and i the last time i used that as to
because i i didn't realize that i used
that for taking attendance but if
there's another form for taking
attendance
i i i guess i don't have it and i don't
know i don't really know if there is one
i'll have uh janet or maybe
representative buco knows because he
clerked for us last term
yeah well so the attendance she used to
come on a red clipboard so it was a
separate sheet
i can have janet connect with you
representative lin and make sure you've
got
the proper documents because she's the
one who collects all those for the you
know the minutes and the
clerk's files so i'll have janet connect
with you to make sure you've got the
right stuff
great thank you and then just one other
question and this is probably the more
important one is um
i've i've been taking notes so to speak
as
as we've had the two presentations and
is i i guess what i'm really asking is
what do i do now am i supposed to like
write up a little
a little report so to speak about what
they said or
what what do i do now
uh yes a little report i mean
with uh you know as we're going through
these
um budget hearings
you know we'll be talking about a lot of
things but
uh janet we just need to put in the
file you know kind of a general
statement about what occurred during
um during these sessions and
the other question when you're talking
to janet is
we need to figure out how all of these
handouts
are going to get into the file
because that is that is the place
where we keep records for
however many years but
janet should be able to figure that out
with you
so daniel madam chair i i would just
i i would take my hand scribbled notes
down the hall and hand them to janet and
she would type everything up so
um i don't i didn't
i didn't submit a summarized report i
gave her actually the
the uh scribbled notes
well i i i think i might try that at
some point when we're
when we're like you know in person but
um
my my i've never been known for having
very clear handwriting
yeah well i can't read my own either so
so i thought you might try at least in
the first instance to type up a little
something
i just asked janet what she needs okay
thank you yeah she she uh she will
definitely
uh tell you what she needs and uh
but we do need to figure out how we're
going to
um get all this stuff into the file
and i think that it will be probably
obviously a little bit later on when we
start getting
written testimony from
that will become it's not a problem
because we'll get it
but we just need to know how to get it
into the file
right okay all right great well thank
you very much
not a problem so we'll see everybody
about 125.
it is wonderful i think it's just this
is running more smoothly than i ever
imagined and
you keep it going i am i think we have
the best division
oh there's no question in my mind mary
excuse me i got a phone ringing here and
this has worked so well
i miss kind of the convincing and you
know note sharing and chit chat
afterwards
and just you know the small talk with
the um the people coming in
but this has worked so well i don't
think we would have had i'm not sure we
would have met with tuesday with the ice
storm
i know i'm not sure i would have wanted
to drive and it was worse where you guys
are than it was here
we might not have had that meeting on
tuesday if we hadn't had zoom
that's right i think it's working really
well i just
um i feel real comfortable i'm anxious
to hear fish and game because
um they've had such a good year but due
to covet actually
they're amazing it sounds like lottery
really um
i don't want to say benefited but um the
revenues did come up from it
yeah and drinking and tobacco yes
sit and hop and drink let's hear it for
the vices
that's what we got but new hampshire
lives on
karen can i ask you a question sure you
know your chair
sometimes i like to ask questions just
because i want to know something a
little bit more it's not necessarily
related
to you know something specific in the
the budget but it's something that
provokes a question in my mind from the
budget and sometimes it leads to an
interesting conversation but i don't
know how comfortable you are with that
i'm comfortable with anything you want
to ask
okay thank you you know we're that's uh
that's one thing i try to make sure we
keep it open
to whatever it is i'm not uh
you know i'm not i'm not going to
tell you not to ask something if it's
something that you want to know
well some of it's some of it is so
interesting and i learned so much
i love finance for that reason this
budget process
is just intriguing and i love it so much
because i've learned so much about new
hampshire
and then mickey mickey is a star he is
so fabulous
i think we have the best lba person ever
too
yeah you also you have to also
understand that he is
extremely patient
okay
i don't see anyone from fishing game
here yet um
there is no handout so if you were
looking for one in your email or
anything
they they didn't have one for today so
um i think they're just going to speak
to
the governor's recommended budget
document now they have a new
commissioner right
yes what's his name scott
mason
yeah kathy labonte has been it with fish
and game for a while
is that who we're gonna hear from today
we're gonna hear from scott okay good
jason
so uh mickey does it look like fish and
game doesn't want any money
they don't need a lot i have uh it looks
like i have
spelaine here with his hand raised i can
bring him in maybe he
has something to share for everybody
okay i don't see his hand raised go
ahead
is janet on the call hi how is everybody
we're fine i just wanted to let you know
that uh that
uh as fish and game committee members we
are also interested
and watching for this we've been working
with uh the fish and game department and
uh they're doing a
fantastic job as you all know uh it's
been
amazing uh that they've been able to do
everything they've done through this
covet epidemic
and uh and they're holding everything
together
um i don't know how long it'll take for
them to jump on but we're
extremely interested in what they have
to say and uh looking forward to their
numbers
aren't we all the chair the chair uh tim
lang is also on
and he he uh may have his own things to
say but i wanted to to
let you know that you know we're we're
interested in the process and we're
we're watching and
and uh here to
facilitate if there's any need for us
okay thank you
uh mickey do you happen to have their
phone number yeah let me uh let me give
them a call
okay uh would you like to hear from
representative lang
he has his hand raised too if he would
like to speak we might as well
fill in the uh the gap here i'll bring
him in
representative okay
i just wanted to let you know i did
reach out to scott mason to remind him
he had this meeting so i already texted
him and let him know
oh you did okay well i'm sure he didn't
forget
i would ask can you tell me the page
number again the governor's bill i'm
trying to catch up to where you guys are
i missed the number
yeah page 596. oh thank you i was
looking for that myself
oh yeah
mickey will talk to somebody over there
so let's see um
i guess we're uh what's today today's
thursday
uh we're not meeting again until monday
and monday we have uh safety and
transportation coming in
i think yeah yeah and um
the 26th um
we have the uh
you is it the yeah the university
what i what i want to talk to them
about is not so much their budget
because i personally have no problem
with what the governor has
outlined in 2022
but what i do want to talk about is
this consolidation of
the two systems and
i am particularly interested of course
in um what hb2 has to say
about that but i know we all listened
yesterday
and the governor sure didn't say much
else than what he had said before
um and so i uh i am
[Music]
i am a little nervous about how
how we want to proceed with that and
um when i was uh
i was talking to catherine provencher
um i guess you know i don't know
we need we need to look very carefully
because
just by just combining the two boards
doesn't solve anything
because there's um you know there's all
kinds of
uh rsas that deal with the
with the two two systems and
uh you can't you can't just say voila
without digging into and figuring out
how all that's going to work and the
other half of the problem is that in
2023 the governor is only giving
a pot of money uh to the
to the two systems so it's
um it's going to be very complicated for
us and i have uh
briefly spoken to um
representative ladd to
try to see what his thought process is
on that
because it is a huge policy issue
and i think you also know that there is
a public higher education
committee uh mary are you on that or
i was the last session yes okay well
i've been appointed to that
this time and i don't remember who the
other person is
um i didn't get appointed so i'm off i
but it's a wonderful group
yes i know i know so i don't know if we
want to think about
challenging them to put this together
what any any legislation that gets
submitted
more than likely wouldn't be effective
until
1 july of 22
which would put the both systems in kind
of a
a catch-22 so anyhow i just
i would just like people to be um you
know prepared for that discussion
whatev wherever it leads because the
governor
didn't say you know he did say the
legislature could say no
you know this is potentially a
multi-year process
that it's not something that you just
flip a switch and one they just
go work together oh gee you think
i agree multiple moving parts of house i
would
i think it seems i would have expected
there to be
a like a process paper or a white paper
to explain
how this would work over time and i
expect there may needs to be if we do
this and it has some merit you know i'm
open to listening to it
yeah well um there may needs to be some
expenditures in order to help
pull these all these different elements
together yeah
well that's that's what our job is going
to be to try to sort all that out
that's why i asked that you get your
thinking caps on
so let us know if i could madam chair if
i could bring us back to fishing game
for one more second
i didn't want to i did want to comment
that one of the things that's in the
budget that's extremely important to us
in fish and game
and has been a a contentious uh issue
for
many many years now is the powder mill
fish hatchery
they have designated money to do
a fix to the outflow
uh since fish and game is not here i
guess i will take it upon myself to
speak to that a little bit in fact that
jim jim they are here oh okay great okay
and i've been waiting for that
in our department we've been waiting for
that and we have constantly been
answering questions from people on that
and and we've finally seen a resolution
and a
an expenditure and we're happy to see
that in our department
okay uh commissioner scott
welcome we have not met before
uh kathy i'm glad to see that
as always you are you are there and
um so if you wouldn't mind
i'd like you to introduce yourself
and provide us with your thoughts on the
governor's budget
uh good afternoon my name is executive
director scott mason new hampshire fish
as guardian of the new hampshire fish
and wildlife and marine resources
the new hampshire fish and game
department works in partnership with the
public
to conserve manage and protect these
resources
and their habitats inform and educate
the public
about these resources provide the public
with opportunities to use
and appreciate these resources
due to covert 19 more and more people
have chosen to recreate
in the out of doors this year we've seen
an increase
in almost every service we provide to
the people of new hampshire
like all state agencies we have
tightened our budgets due to the
economic impacts that cobit
is having on our state resources
it will be very hard for us to meet all
the historic needs and these increased
needs that citizens are currently
asking for with the budget that we have
proposed
while i've only been here for a few
short months it has become very apparent
to me
in this short period of time the
department is
is critically resource challenged from
both a personnel
side and a financial side we have 192
full-time authorized positions
including myself this budget includes
10 unfunded positions including four
conservation officers two
biologists a hyper a hatchery supervisor
and two staff in our public affairs
division and
and uh landowner relations each and
every one of these positions
um in 20 in his fiscal year 2020
we ended with a seven point um
six million dollar um
fishing game fund unusually high
revenues in the spring of 2020
due to the pandemic this this has been
recognized nationally
currently fiscal year 2021 overall
budget
is proposed at 34 million 2022 in 2023
at 33.85 million and 35.12 million
respectively
keeping in mind there are 27 pay periods
in the second year
of the biennium uh general fund
appropriations have helped the fish and
game fund over the last four bienniums
our budget request has 600
dollars each year of general fund money
a hundred thousand in match to our
non-game program
uh per rsa 212 uh
b cohen six two and five hundred
thousand the law enforcement
au 7887
the governor's budget director provided
us with a figure of 1.2 million over the
over the biennium to us um our inland
fisheries division recent our inland
fisheries division
chief recently has given notice of his
resignation
his departure has increased the pressure
on the department as
we look to solving the problems of
carter mill hatchery the departing
division chief has previously held both
the position of hatchery supervisor and
has been serving
as chief in both capacity since 2013.
those are my opening statements and if
committee
yes representative thank you madam chair
um and thank you um
for taking my question um from
my what you suggested is that a fishing
game has had a
really strong revenue could you just
talk
about that a little bit how um what
areas
that you saw the huge increases and how
you um how you were able to
uh provide uh support and resources
for the um multitude of people that came
through our state
taking advantage of our wonderful
resources
you know when the pandemic struck in in
the spring of the year
uh we saw a marked increase in license
you know license sales um that continued
through the summer with
increased uh atv and or i should say
ohrv
registration fees um the other thing
that took place is we saw a marked
increase
in um hunting license sales early in the
spring
for those of you we have a spring
turkey season so quite often folks that
don't turkey hunt may wait till the end
of the year to buy their license but
this year
a lot of them had time in the spring to
try turkey hunting so we sold a large
increase in not only turkey permits but
also in hunting licenses in the spring
um we
we have healthy herds and flocks
in new hampshire of the of our species
that that are hunted
um we have had uh we have a very decent
program for our
hatchery uh trout program and we have a
good
warm water resources warm water fish
resources
and i don't believe that the increased
pressure has caused any negative impacts
it certainly is an uptick but the other
thing that goes on and anybody that
hunts or fishes can explain to you
if you don't have a it take it's not
something that that
you necessarily go do the first day and
become very successful now there are
there are times that you're very
successful on that first day but
a lot of times it takes you know
multiple trips out to the woods before
you actually get your first turkey
um or fish or whatever whatever you're
you're after
um but the other thing that took place
is with all these extra people in the
woods that meant you know more people
were out hiking
and that meant we probably i haven't we
have not run the actual final statistic
so i would
hesitate to say that we actually saw an
uptick but we did seem to
be spending a little bit more time
looking for lost souls
um and we had some um rather horrendous
you know issues this this past summer uh
with some of our lost
goals in the woods um and uh that's
continued into this year with i'm sure
you guys read the newspapers about some
of the accidents and some of the lost
folks we've been dealing with
through the winter um and
it uh that does it you know it's an
expensive process for fish and game to
supply those services
yes i do thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question
uh search and rescue uh we have a people
who pay into that fund
and how does that that that budget how
does that look like
as far as expenditures um
we that was something else that we saw
record sales on
i'm sure you folks are familiar with the
hike safe card
and i don't kathy do you have the
numbers pulled out
i do actually i have the final report
for search and rescue that was submitted
to fiscal committee
as of june 30th and i can do a breakdown
of those revenues for you
the hike safe card that was implemented
a few years ago
has enjoyed much more success than i
think was originally anticipated
and the hike safe card for fiscal year
actually um brought in 165
795 dollars in revenue
the agency response fee which is that
fee that is paid to us for people who
have been deemed
negligent that we have had to rescue
was twenty two thousand four hundred
twenty three dollars
and the remaining balance which is fees
and donations which is kind of a
melting pot of course is one dollar for
every
snow machine and ohrv registration
as well as every boat registration that
goes into this
pot and that was a hundred and ninety
seven
thousand dollars 184 dollars and fifty
cents
so for the second year in a row the
search and rescue account
actually closed out in the positive
which we have not seen in a very long
time
we closed out with a paul positive
balance of 171
708.35
for fiscal year 20. and i brought this
with me because there's
always questions about search and rescue
i know you're always interested in that
and any representatives i was just going
to point the committee to page 627 of
the governor's budget document you'll
see those figures that kathy just
uh discussed for fiscal 20 so there's a
separate accounting unit
uh for search and rescue so just so you
can
crosswalk from her explanation to the
budget document
kathy maybe you could uh forward that
to um janet or mickey so that we can get
that in the record
because this is a uh so i mean it's
so unusual to have this area actually in
the plus column
this document is actually a fiscal
committee report that i file with the
fiscal committee on a quarterly basis
so it's already gone through the lba but
if you would like for me to forward it
over there again i can certainly do that
yeah i would i would appreciate that so
that
okay our our committee doesn't
necessarily get
all of the information that goes to
fiscal
so certainly yeah uh okay i need
if i could i wanted to ask a question
about the um
the hike safe cards does this also
cover skiers or it or do we have a
similar program for skiers
the back country people that seem to be
having a lot of trouble this year
we don't have a specific program for
skiers but
yes if a skier bought a hike safe car i
mean part of
back country skiing you know it's it's
it's partially hiking it's partially
skiing you know you're hiking up to ski
back down
there's no reason why they couldn't buy
the other thing and people don't
understand sometimes but
part of your hunting license and fishing
license
and that's where fishing game gets
started looking for people is is
is they will go get you if you're out
hunting fishing they'll they'll go find
you if you don't come
home and it it's
um it's the best of our ability
but that's included in the price of a
hunting and fishing license so
um if somebody has a fishing license
then
they're somewhat protected under that
yeah i'm sorry i didn't have my i was
still on mute
uh representative buco you have a
question
yes thank you manchester so i at my at
first glance at the source of funds i
see that
um you've been able to cut down on the
use of general funds by almost
two-thirds
and and more than made it up in uh fish
and game funds and other funds
so i was kind of surprised to hear you
say that the department is
severely challenged where where are you
challenged with
what sorts of funds are you are not
making up
um we are challenged in the fact that
we probably need more cos than we
currently staff
and if we fill you know if we fill the
open positions that we have in cos
um we wouldn't be able to meet the
budget targets that the governor had
suggested to us
um and some of some of our
some of these other open staff positions
that have gone unfunded over the years
are are places where we should um
try to seek funding but um
with the budget crisis that we're
looking at right now
with uh you know coming off a covered
knight you know covert 19
i think it's you know like all
departments we need to tighten our belts
as best we can and keep going
it also wasn't a
like an open that we could just say we
needed this much general funds we were
provided
a number of general funds this is all
you can have
and this is the governor's target dollar
value of what you have to meet
so you have to make your budget work
and that is why we have those 10
unfunded positions
thank you uh representative
murray you have a question yeah thank
you i had some line item questions too i
don't know if we should do
that later on um but i guess right now i
got a partial answer to it i think
before
you said that there's a 600 000 from
general funds
and in the budget i found the five
hundred thousands but i can't find
i'm missing the hundred thousand you
said something about a match
but where do i find that hundred
thousand in the budget it's on
uh it's on page 602 it's on the exact
on the first page of the budget in
accounting unit which 5068
it's on sorry i was looking at one of my
questions but it's on
uh it's right at the very beginning okay
at the very bottom of the page that's
why i don't find that
so that went up from 50 to 100 000
recently
yes
[Music]
murray go ahead with your other
questions is um
can you speak to the debt service this
is on page 603
um it's gone down significantly um
just a word about how that is going
well the reason for that is there was
two or three bienniums that we did not
put in any capital budget request
and the reason for that is we knew that
we were not going to
have the funding to pay those 20-year
bonds back
so for this biennium i reduced our
debt service it will definitely go up in
the next biennium we've had
for this past biennium we have had
capital budget requests out there and we
certainly
have a big one out there that we're
requesting now in this
new biennium coming up for the powder
thank you on 610 contracts for program
services is am i on the right line
yeah what was that that's gone away
completely is that something that you
were cutting that you didn't want to go
away or is that a
program that's simply gone actually
class 102
uh das informed us that class 102 is not
an appropriate class to use for what we
were using it for class 103 is more
appropriate
so if you go through our budget anywhere
any accounting unit that had a class 102
we have zeroed them out in
615 where that
where's that 360 000 coming from on
intra-agency transfer 0-9
that's new i assume it's coming from
someplace else but i wasn't able to
that is the same type of class line
switch if you look down
on class 217 interagency payments
for fiscal years 20 and 21 there was
a large expense there and for 22 and 23
it is zeroed out that expense went up to
class 29.
thank you and
uh what land acquisition and easements
do you do
that's 6 17. i said that's in the budget
from last time and before it's gone up
but can you speak about your program for
uh do you want to speak to that or
we have an active program um where we
purchase
usually we're purchasing easements but
sometimes it's in fee
um and the purpose is usually to
uh protect have you know crucial
habitats in the state
um it also one of the requirements we do
is
is that it when we put an easement on a
piece of property
it will allow for public trespass
including hunting fishing and traffic
unless we're in a very specific
habitat where we're trying to protect
some you know an endangered species or
something
where that type of trespass would
threaten the species at that question
thank you and one last thing you weren't
here i don't know if you were here the
last time can you update me on the
blending turtles and the cottontails i
see that those programs are
zeroed out now i worry about those
turtles
um i'm afraid i wasn't here last year so
i'm not sure what was
said last year state wildlife grants
are a little bit different than a
regular ongoing appropriation of
pr and dj grants meaning they are
competitive grants
at the federal level and they were given
out specifically
for those programs and the grants that
we received were named specifically new
england cottontail and blandings
that does not mean in any way that we
are not continuing work on those species
we just do not have a specific grant
named for that species
at this point in time so don't you worry
about the turtles or the cottontails
thank you very much thank you madam
chair for letting me go on here
not a problem representative petry
yes thank you mayor chair and thank you
for taking my question uh
of course we know we got stars with uh
on northwoods law
how much revenue do we recognize from
that
the state doesn't um each
episode i believe pays a fee of 2500
and that goes to the new hampshire
wildlife heritage
uh foundation they in turn
write grants to fish and game they they
also do other fundraisers
uh you know besides that but they all
then they turn around and write grants
specifically to new hampshire
fish and game for specific issues
they underwrite our canine program very
heavily
search and rescue issues you know maybe
equipment
that kind of stuff as well as it could
be programming now going back to the new
england cottontail
uh you're pushing my ability
there is a disease that's running
through rabbits right now
and we're putting up a boundary fence
around uh
one of our facilities that does research
on a new england cottontail
and and the foundation paid for it
wrote a grant to do that one of the
other very successful programs they did
um
at our hatcheries um
basically uh what what's gone on is is
it
um basically they've granted us money to
build greenhouse structures over our
raceways
and on on these instead of having like
like plastic like you'd see in a plant
greenhouse
on the pipes it's actually netting
and this is used to keep uh wild uh
predators out of our hatcheries and it's
it's it's it's made a huge difference
made a huge difference almost a ten
percent difference in survivability of
our trout running through the hatcheries
um so they've done they underwrite a lot
representative lynn you had a question
yes thank you
madam chair um yeah i wonder if i could
ask um
on page 617 towards the bottom
the uh classification 217
the interagency transfer there it went
from 300
000 to 493 i'm just wondering is that
another one where
classification is just a classification
change
i'm sorry are we looking at the on 217
okay page 617 yeah uh
down towards the bottom line 217 i think
it goes from
300 am i reading that correctly it goes
from 300 000. to
uh well i'm sorry i'm i'm reading
four it's research i guess maybe i'm
sorry it's research and management is
that correct it goes from 300 000 to 493
that is correct and we actually fund a
lot of
a lot of research contracts especially
with unh
and other partners
so have you ever may have asked a
follow-up
certainly yeah so in other words i so
you have a
almost a 200 000 increase in that could
you just
talk a little bit about what that's for
i would not be the expert
sir to talk about that that would be
more the wildlife division chief
um i'm not the expert on the wildlife
habitat account
and when we when we
do budget i can say this when we do
budget we it we have
anticipated future expenditures
based on what we think potentially could
be
coming down the pipeline
i do know that we use this class line
for a lot of rental equipment a lot of
on the ground work
at our wildlife management areas
be happy to uh sit down and chat with
the wildlife
chief and we'll get back to you with a
exact answer we we could do that
okay yeah that would be that would be
uh did you have anything else
representative lynn
i i did not thank you very much okay
uh representative petry i think you were
next
thank you madam chair uh thank you for
taking my next question
uh windmills and bird strikes do we
record how many birds we take out
are they reported to you and what is
your budget
is that a big budget or i don't imagine
would be a big one but uh is there a
cost involved
i don't believe i know anything about
that yeah i i
once again i'm afraid i don't know um
an answer to the question let me speak
to our folks i know
um once again let me speak to my
wildlife department i'll get back to you
with an answer on that
thank you very much representative heath
you had a question
um my my question is on um page 634
and it's not a big increase but i'm more
curious about the overall
um line item um it's
um statewide public boat access
and everything we've gone through um i
see it's it's an increase of um
just about 60 000 but
um it seems like there'd be more um
action around that line um considering
the number of
tourists and and people that are using
those public boat accesses right now can
you just describe what's happening how
did it go
um did you see huge increases over the
summer
did it work well or did it have problems
yes it worked well yes we saw increases
yes we have problems yes we have
problems um
other than that no no uh
that's funded when somebody registers
their boat
so unless boat you know when boat
registration numbers change
that's that's how that funds out to us
um
so if you register your boat and use it
once
it doesn't matter how many times you use
it so um
in the year like last year i'm sure
people got out and did a lot more with
their boats
than they normally do so it increased it
um
the other issue that shows up is is we
had a lot of non-boaters i mean
a boat ramp becomes a access to water
for people that aren't
um boating and uh um
we the other source of income is
is is a we use this we use the money
coming in from the boat
registrations as a state match with
federal money
when we take the federal money one of
the strings that's attached to that
is the only thing that can take place at
a boat landing is let you know
launching boats and recovering boats not
you know it's not a place to go swimming
it's not a place for fishing
et cetera et cetera so we have to
actually make sure that that
activity doesn't take place um
which can create some issues from time
to time but at the end of the day we've
been able to live with it pretty well
um and and try to get people to go to
other places
our basic issue is if it's not a safety
issue then we try not to
you know be too aggressive in the
enforcement of it but if it becomes a
safety issue then we really do need to
be
uh excuse let me interrupt just a second
i'm sorry
uh are there any capital projects this
year for boat ramps or are we
um we're finishing one up on alton bay
it's not a capital
oh i'm sorry no i'm not a catholic
my my mistake we are finishing up a
large
boat landing at alton bay it's not a
capital project
um but it it is over a million dollars
so it's a public
um works right it is going through dpw
yes and that's one of our bigger
projects that i think we've done on boat
landings
um i believe we've got two other boat
landings that they'll be working on this
year
but they're much smaller in size and
steel
repairs and you know one of the problems
that happens with boat launches
you know sand moves in so we we're
constantly out doing
even minor repairs but and then of
course sometimes you're out there
quite often these boat launches are
either plank
or or concrete ties that are
that are chained or roped together and
we need to get in and you know do some
maintenance and whatnot on some of the
structures
thank you very much representative
murray
thank you madam chair um i have my hike
state cards by the way my husband and i
have our hike safe so um since we're on
the public boat access i've well one
question there and then just another
question
what do the consultants do you've got an
uptick in consultancy fees here
can you give an example of what the
consultants do and my second question
is can you address your your federal
funds is that a reliable source of
funding i know that some agencies stress
what the federal government's going to
do
um are the federal funds that come to
you are you are they
do you feel secure and the federal
funding in terms of how that money comes
to you
do you think let me know does that make
sense do you understand what i'm trying
to ask
yeah absolutely and the federal funds
are very
elegant to the second part first the
federal funding is very secure
it's part of our um uh dj funds right
bengal johnson
part of idj funds they are very secure
it's an annual apportionment
from the feds every every year the
reason why
you see an uptick in class 46 the only
thing that line is used for
is a contract with our engineering
consultants
and every couple years we do go out to
bid for that
and the reason why it's 125 000 in the
first year of this budget is
for the project at alton bay the
downings landing project
that is going to be coming in as the
director said it over a million dollars
between the federal funds and the state
match it's a very large project there's
going to be a lot of engineering fees
i would record you all for those of you
that are familiar where
you know as you come up route 16 when
you first start seeing the waters of
lake winnipesaukee right there in alton
um the the east side of the lake that's
where this piece of property is it's
right at the very beginning of the lake
and it um it's a beautiful piece of
property
and it was a great opportunity the
fishing game was able to purchase it a
few years ago
and we've been kind of pitching away at
building the land and this
this summer we hope to finish it and i
encourage you all if you're in that
neighborhood to stop by and take a quick
peek
it's very critical that we hold on to
our boat access
funds in the dedicated account because
we're counting on those to pay for this
project
representative lynn you had a question
yes uh thank you madam chair um
uh commissioner murray i wonder um you
uh with regard to the ten
positions that you uh that um are
are vacant and unfunded could you just
tell us
how long how long have those positions
i don't have that information in front
of me
um i can okay i can give you a
uh round idea the
four conservation officers have been
vacant
for at least the last three bienniums
so for several years
the two positions in our public affairs
division
the same thing they have been vacant for
at least
the wildlife biologist position at least
the last
landowner relations justice
current biennium um
and the fisheries biologists
at least three bienniums and then the
new
the number 10 we're just unfunding is
another fisheries biologist
um no i'm sorry that wasn't a fishery a
fisheries biologist i'm sorry
that was the hatchery manager position
that has been at least three bienniums
all right thank you very much you're
welcome
so these are basically not new unfunded
positions
we only have one that is new the nine
other ones are not new they're currently
unfunded for this biennium and they were
unfunded
the last biennium all right thank you
very much
are there oh uh representative petry you
thank you madam chair uh and thank you
for taking this new question
um ticks where are we at on that and uh
what are we
what kind of money are we throwing at
um which ticks are you referencing sir
the deer ticks in this here i
didn't realize we had a problem in both
places but uh
well one one set of ticks that moose
ticks are
are quite harmful to our northern moose
population
that ticks that um create lyme disease
in humans
that's a different tip they're not
there's a bunch of different ticks in
the world they're not all the same
um so if you're talking about lyme
disease
um i don't think we deal with that in
this department
really but do we i mean what what are we
doing about the ticks
you know i i haven't seen a moose uh in
the south here for a while
and uh you know i know we've talked
about it in the past of uh
yeah um well we've actually kind of
this year we're suggesting a little
different management technique with our
moose population
and we've bifurcated the state um
the issue up north are the ticks that
in fact that latch onto the moose and
basically what happens
this time of year from now until the end
of winter beginning of
the spring up north um these ticks
basically bleed the moose out and and it
does two things number one it
kills the younger moves the yellow and
most and number two is
it it reduces the reproductive
um success
of other moves so instead of having a
set of twins you end up with a single um
that that or or she's not able to have a
successful birth
and and raise a calf up to being a
yearling um so
so it's depleted our population
um there's been research at
and it sounds a little counter-intuitive
but maine and vermont have been pursuing
a course where they're trying to reduce
the number of moose
in this in this particular and it is a
kind of a
a southern uh a southern bottom to the
zone and a northern bottom to the zone
uh so like if you get up into canada you
can actually get above this zone of
ticks but
from like grafton north of new hampshire
from northern grafton county north it
falls into the zone
where these ticks live and what we're
trying to do is reduce the number a
little bit and hopefully
that in turn will reduce the number of
ticks and allow the population to move
to rebound
the southern part of the state it's a
what happens there is is um you have
brain
worm that gets that impacts the the
moose population down there
and reduces the moose population and
um there we are trying to
we've uh reduced uh the moose tags that
we're going to be
we've suggested that we reduce the
number of moose tags that we will be
issuing
over the next hunting seasons in the
southern southern tier
of the state to try to rebound the
population a bit down there
thank you representative murray i
believe you were next
thank you again madam chair when you say
unfunded
is that unfilled or are you saying that
there are other people who are covering
these positions that aren't funded can
you just clarify when you say unfunded
is that a person who
is not working there or is someone kind
of doing double time
taking care of the fish hatcheries if
you have an un funded position there
unfunded is an authorized position
number that has no funding associated
with
it for the biennium meaning we cannot
fill it we have no authority to fill it
because there's no funds associated with
it
so unfunded is unfilled correct
and so are there other people covering
this or is there stuff not getting done
uh there is stuff not getting done
and there are other people covering what
can be covered
so thank you
representative heath my question
continues with that topic
so if we were to populate those funds
would that equate to higher revenues in
fish and game
so are we being penny foolish by not
populating those lines with people and
would it result in
higher income and what might that
possibly be
well it depends on how you know it
depends on which positions
um if you give me more cos that probably
is not going to
increase um license sales
what it does do is it helps to increase
safety
for example i can't remember the date
but a couple weekends ago
coming from the north country's a little
different than the rest of the state uh
we might be a little bit more laid back
i i actually get people stopping at my
farm
and talking to my wife about problems
with fish and game now so it's
it's a very different type of atmosphere
up north than it is in other places
so on a saturday afternoon at two
o'clock in the afternoon my phone rings
and it's somebody complaining about snow
machines driving off trail
on private property being disrespectful
and causing
problems which um being off trail is
is a ticketable offense but in general
you know negative interaction between
outdoors people and landowners usually
ends up in
landowners shutting their property down
to outdoor activities so
the fishing game takes these these these
calls very very seriously
um so i i got a hold of our colonel
and he was getting ready to dis he
dispatched a
co to go to this town in stewart's town
and before we could get
up to stewart's town we had two calls
that
that we that were rescue calls hiking
rescue calls
one of which we flew national guard
helicopter the airlift a
a person off the side of one of the
mountains and in grafton county and the
other one
uh the weather had getting so bad the
helicopter no longer could fly and we
were dispatching two groups of people to
climb the mountain to try to rescue
these folks
and then we ended up by four o'clock we
had four more
uh snowmobile wrecks and we had to
dispatch cos to that
so the co that was supposed to go up and
try to
catch these folks never got there until
the next the next day
and um that's what we run into is
especially on weekends
busy times we run out of cos we have 41
cos in the state
um the entire state
and uh city of concord has more police
officers than we have ceos
and and i understand it's a different
job i understand it's a
um you know a different level of
staffing
but at the same time we are spread
pretty soon
um now one of the places like in our
communications department uh there's a
program in
the world of fishing game called r3 and
what it's all about
re r3 is what recruit retrain
recruitment
retain and reactivate um license holders
so what it's about
is how do you get somebody and we have
different types like like i've always
bought my license by
you know the end of january i
religiously go buy a hundred and fishing
license
uh so you got people like me and you
have other people that might buy one
every five years every 10 years
trying to get those folks to buy more
often and then you've also got
other folks that just didn't get exposed
to hunting and fishing growing up and
and trying to get them to try it and buy
a license
and this is a national program that a
lot of states have bought
into and have been working hard at uh to
try to increase their license sales
so that would be an example of where a
position might help us
thank you for anyone else with questions
because i
but director mason my question is as i
went through
your budget it appears that you are
moving people around within the various
departments
could you kind of explain that a little
bit
uh i'm not sure we are
moving people around what we did
representative
umberger is um in order to meet
the governor's target we moved
several positions from accounting units
that were
funded mainly by fish and game funds
into dedicated sources of funding
in order to free up some fish and game
funds
we moved a couple of people from
fisheries into the fisheries
habitat account which is dedicated we
moved
two conservation officers in the
northernmost part of the state
from accounting unit 7887 into
dedicated account 1183 ohrv
representative hamburger you have you
need to turn the mute button we can't
sorry um for example
under um statewide public
boat access yes you go from two to three
and so that was that was my question was
were they
were the areas where you moved the
people short
or was it because of your
ability to fund within that particular
area
it was in order to meet
the guidelines that we were provided by
the governor's office
and maintain our 192
people without having to let anybody go
okay i have another question and this
deals with
um if i'm not mistaken here
it shows the uh
commission with a two million dollar
budget
and maybe i'm reading it wrong but it uh
what people ask what page you're on
i uh i i check marked it but
now of course i can't find it but
oh you're on page 602 at the end of that
yeah that number there representative
umberger is a subtotal
okay i was waiting for a question mickey
i'm sorry okay i think
so okay so the um
the x oh that's it says expenditure
total for fish and game commission
is 2 million that's a subtotal of the
accounts above it
for that um section of their budget
okay so this is all the wildlife stuff
no we refer to this section of the
budget as the office of the director
it's not under a specific division like
the wildlife division the business
division
public affairs law enforcement this
first section of the budget
is the office of the director or
fish and game commission is what it's
referred to
so that is the subtotal
of that section of the department
so like our grant writer works in my
works in the commissioner's office uh
our ag
works in the commissioner's office we
have well it's all those accounting
rights right yeah so this is all the
accounts from the beginning of fish and
game
through page 602 correct
okay all right fine i'm i'm like this
didn't make any sense to me so
no that is correct i appreciate that
okay uh i do have some i think
that includes if i may say a big portion
of that
is our transfers to doit
that interagency transfer to the
department of information technology
which is well over nine hundred thousand
dollars
what what's your 600
you can see that in 600 that transfer to
oit eoit yeah
okay um you had mentioned dispatch
and i think i heard the governor say the
fish and game
we believe that that's going to be in
hb2
um
how many people in fish and game are
associated with dispatch one full time
three part time
i'm sorry what one full-time and three
part-time people
but one of the issues that takes place
is our dispatch
um does more than just um dispatch cos
and uh the plan will be that we will
maintain
one of our phone lines in and
that will create and you know they'll
deal with people calling in looking for
answers to questions about wildlife
issues that they are having
at home um you know you got a bear
what do i how do i get a bear out of my
garage how do i
you know stop a bear from attacking my
chickens um
what do i do with a skunk or my front
door yard um
we receive a lot of questions like that
so we're gonna have to
restructure uh the way we manage some of
our outreach to these folks
uh traditionally it's gone through our
dispatch and it's handled that way
um so the uh right now the plan is for
us to continue to manage that here
okay so um of the one full time
and three part time how many will be
retained one
sorry i keep forgetting to unmute myself
so uh
one full time will remain correct
and he'll be called uh
outreach person yeah we don't have a
title we haven't done it yet
i'll be back with you in uh in just uh
um on the land
acquisition and easements
are you planning any large purchases
this year
or or is this mostly uh
easement kind of
quite often it's mostly easement we
we are looking at several parcels uh
currently
um but i i
i'm not sure i just i'm not sure i can
say whether they're big or small at this
point
are those mostly up north or are they
down south
all over the state which creates the
issue with big and small
um a small piece of property we're
actually looking at a piece
let me it's in the exeter area i won't i
won't say
definitely exeter but this is a small
it's a very small piece of property but
it it hooks up with a bunch of other
properties
and it helps us uh to defend a rather
large uh
conservation area um
and so i approve the i approved our
people going forward
whether we actually get there or not i
don't know um
but up north you can obviously buy more
more acres for your dollar than you can
down south but
and especially when you get critical
habitat some you know
there are habitats that you got to be
down south by and they don't exist up in
the north country so
the other place that over the years fish
and game has
spent quite a bit of money is around
great bay and you know we're obviously
not
the only folks down there nature
conservancy
i believe u.s fish and wildlife service
and others have have uh
protected a large area around great bay
but it's certainly one of our special
special areas in the state
how do how do you um work between
fish and game and the other conservation
things that are all around the state do
you have
working agreements with them or is it
often a sharing on a piece of property
we you know we might hold an easement
where they
they own it outright or you know we
different groups will come together with
money
and and buy you know buy parcels um
and but then each parcel will have its
have its own
uh uh easement or i don't want to say an
mou but
at least the plan on how to manage that
that piece of land
uh but yes we do work with other
conservation organizations quite well in
the state of new hampshire
um um both the large ones and also
okay
but we have a person in our agency that
maintains those relationships
okay um as i'm looking at
the uh last page of your budget
it shows that you have an
increase of one position
in 2022
from 2019 or 2020 and 2021
it goes from 190 to 191
interested in uh
you know as i mentioned before i saw a
lot of changes
throughout your uh out your budget in
the number of um
[Music]
solutions but that position
is represented on page 632
that position is the result of a
very large donation uh
benefactor if you will is that what you
call a person who makes a very large
donation
to our great bay sandy point
research center and
this is a donation that is going to go
on for many many many years
a million dollars a year she wanted to
the reader's digest version is
we created a class 59 which is
temporary full-time
100 percent funded by the proceeds of
this donation
to be a management
or a program management position out at
our sandy
uh great bay research reserve and
that is where that position will be and
it will be funded
in perpetuity by this donation from this
benefactor
oh that that's that's wonderful that's
absolutely wonderful i don't know who
arranged for that but
yes i know those things don't come easy
that's
that's uh that's for darn sure so
are there any other questions that
okay if i'm not mistaken we've got
uh a couple of items that you need to
get back to us on
one was on uh one minute um
um mark ellingwood is chief of our
wildlife division and he just joined us
and i think he could answer one of those
questions for you
oh okay great thank you very much
good afternoon my name is mark
ellingwood it's pleasure to meet you
i understand you had a question
regarding
increases in habitat expenditures in the
2155 org 304 yep
mark we can hardly hear you i'm sorry i
yeah thank you thank you that's
much better okay good so uh
regarding the habitat increased
expenditures
i simply wanted to mention that those
monies which
are both federal funds matched with
dedicated habitat camp revenue those
increases reflect a significant increase
in investments and infrastructure on the
80 000 or so acres that we manage and
oversee
throughout the state the commission
through policy
has directed us to uh to
intensify fire management of those
properties and those expenditures are a
reflection of that effort
the type of work done in that
circumstance includes the maintenance of
roads
replacement of undersized culverts the
establishment of parking areas
and the placement of educational kiosks
in addition there's some additional
money being spent in that or
in that specific class for
non-commercial habitat management on
those
oh yeah you need to unmute yourself
so sorry uh can you answer the bird
strike
question all right i'll take a stab at
it and tell you that
we don't expand appreciable funds
related to that
except as it pertains to the sighting of
those types of
facilities we try to guide
all interests in a state in terms of how
to minimize potential impacts
typically permits that provide for the
establishment of
wind farms as an example require that
the actual
commercial interests collect that data
we have access to it
but we're not specifically spending
money in that regard
so the commercial entities provide that
i believe we have access to it through
their data collection
yes do they provide
also the best fish and uh joe does that
i think that'll suffice for the time uh
i think it's going to be a problem and
the more
wind farms we put up because we're
losing you know
eagles and uh you know protected birds
uh thank you mark
if an eagle is struck does that go to us
or does that go
to u.s fish and wildlife service um that
would go to the u.s
fish and wildlife service specifically
but we are close partners with them and
that information would be shared with us
as well
there's a close partnership there i'm
not
aware of that happening here
specifically we don't have substantial
wind power farms at this point but we're
keenly aware of the controversies and
the potential if
misplaced to have adverse impacts so we
very much appreciate your interest in
the subject
thank you very much are there any
further questions that anyone has
for fishing game representative i just
would like to clarify something with uh
kathy on the debt service specifically
we talked about that earlier
um does the debt service line kathy
include
um if the powder mill hatchery in the
well yes it would however if it is
approved by the time that
treasury actually goes out and secures
those bonds
it will the timing of it i really don't
anticipate
too much of that debt being repaid
within this biennium
okay so in all actuality okay
so there's no contingency on what you
have appropriated in there based on that
capital budget item
close this this area and if we have
further questions
um we'll definitely get back to you but
uh
thank you for um your openness and
candidness
and um i think that uh
based on what what i saw and reviewed uh
your budget is very good and that
problems from uh division two i'm only
speaking for myself
i can't speak for anybody else but uh i
thought you did a good job
and uh and thank you so much and by the
way director mason
welcome aboard i know that uh you
haven't been there long
but we're uh we're happy to have you and
um
unfortunately you're sitting at the far
end of the table so it's hard to
make out your facial features but that's
okay well
i'm sure that uh sometime in the near
future
we'll have an opportunity to uh
to meet face to face and i know you've
got a lot of
other issues out there with uh with fish
and game
uh committee and i'm sure that
uh we'll we'll find all kinds of things
going on but
thank you so much you and kathy for uh
for the great job that you've done and
for the uh division two i will
see all of you on monday morning
thank you great thank you very much yep
have a nice weekend and um
i only have two meetings tomorrow so um
i hope none of you have any so good luck
and uh
and take care we'll see you on monday
bye